okay good morning everybody Welcome to
the
Monday January 29th edition of the
science technology and energy committee
we have a full agenda today six public
hearings and we will begin promptly as
soon as representative Noel leads us in
the Pledge of
Allegiance I pledge to the flag of the
United States of America the repic for
stands one nation under God individual
with liy and justice for
all okay so we'll be having public
hearings this morning on three bills HB
1431 relative to utility requirements
for integrated distribution
planning hb1 1465 dfn relative to
studies of nuclear energy
Technologies and
hb-508 requiring fiber optic
Communication service providers to
prioritize service restoration for
Public Safety and public health
organizations and then after a lunch
break we will have three more public
hearings and I will read the titles of
those as we get closer to that
time I would ask everybody who's here to
testify this morning on the three bills
that I just mentioned to be mindful of
the fact that it's a busy day for the
committee and we very much need our
lunch break from 12 to 1 or 12ish to
oneish so I would ask you all as you
testify on these bills to be mindful of
the time you're taking to be as succinct
as possible try not to repeat what other
people are are saying so that we can
have some assurance that we can get out
of here in time to relax a little bit
between a busy morning and what will be
a busy
afternoon and so with that I'm going to
open a public hearing on the first bill
which is HB 1431 relative to utility
requirements for inter integrated
distribution planning and ask the Bill's
Prime sponsor representative Tony Kaplan
to introduce this legislation to
us Good morning Tony good morning uh Mr
chair and good morning fellow members uh
congratulations on making this morning
was not an easy
commute um so uh for the record my name
is Tony Kaplan I'm repres resentative
marac 8 towns of hener Bradford and
Warner and I'm here to uh present hb1
1431 on uh relative to utility
requirements for integrated distribution
planning um I think we are all aware of
the history of the LCP statute which was
uh killed last year in the Senate
Omnibus Bill that came down to us uh and
uh it also appeared in a in a in a house
bill and the argument I remember at the
time for for killing it was that that
the LCP statute was an out outdated
statute coming from the days when the
utilities own their own uh generation
sources and uh it had fallen into disuse
and uh disrepute and was no longer
really any service at all so uh we
killed it off the problem with that is
that it is the only statute that gives
the utility the Public Utilities
Commission the uh statutory authority to
carry out its oversight duty of
balancing the needs of private
shareholders with the needs of the
public to receive a service in a
beneficial manner um so I I seem to
recall at the time the word on the
street that was that we were going to
try to bring this back in some form or
other so this bill HB 1431 is an attempt
to do that it's an attempt to give the
Public Utilities Commission the
statutory authority to carry out its
oversight Duty and to give the public
the the needed weight it needs on on its
side in the form of a a requirement for
the utilities to carry out a long-term
strategic uh Vision visioning visioning
plan of what their needs are balanced
and integrated with the needs of the
public in terms of Public Health in
terms of the environmental impacts and
in terms of cost impacts of their
strategic needs and their infrastructure
needs um so that's what this bill is I
have shared an amendment with you or at
least I I uh shared it by email I've got
copies here and I'd like to pass us out
now and basically the amendment is to
fix two deficiencies if I can just
describe it really briefly the original
bill has no word no language in it uh uh
about Gas Utilities and also has no
enforceability mechanism and I think
we'd all agree that uh you know a
requirement with no enforceability
mechanism is a useless requirement um so
those are the two main differences
between the amendment and the original
bill as you see it before you
um so I think that's it in a nutshell uh
this is basically an attempt to
reinstate the statutory Authority that
we need for the Public Utilities
Commission to carry out its duty to
oversee the utilities in a balanced
manner between the the needs of its of
the private shareholders of the
utilities and the needs of the public to
receive a service in a beneficial manner
you know in essence right now we have a
vehicle that's running on three
cylinders uh and my view is that if we
don't get it into the shop to fix it it
it's you know it might carry on working
and get us to point B but it might just
suffer a breakdown so this is a guard
rail it's a necessary uh it's a
necessary part of the mechanism to make
the the Public Utilities Commission
function in the way it's intended to do
and uh I'm happy to answer any questions
about the original bill or the
amendment thank you representative cap
questions for the
representative representative Thomas has
a question thank you Mr chair um can you
just describe how this bill um allows
for public input which is an important
thing that was removed when we when this
um statute was killed thank you yeah I
mean the uh the the requirement for the
utilities to file a plan uh is is in the
in the context of an a judicative
proceeding which means that it's a it
has has to be duly noted in a public
Manner and the public has access to
those proceedings um and and so that
that is really where the public has some
input and and some feedback into the
plan additional questions representative
McGee has a question thank you Mr
chairman and uh thank you representative
Kaplan for taking my question and for
bringing this bill I'm looking at um the
amendment that was sent out to us is
that what we should be referring to yes
it's at the at the pleasure of the chair
really I'm I'm happy to answer questions
about the amendment the amendment is for
information purposes only
okay we'll discuss it in detail and at
length at a work session and an
executive session okay that's it just
was in my book so I wanted to make sure
I was looking at the right thing the my
question is around um the second piece
you spoke of which is the enforcement
mechanism that's intended in the bill
could you say a little more about that
well I mean the the original bill has no
enforcement mechanism it allows the
utilities to submit a plan uh if the
plan is rejected they have up to a year
to submit another plan and then that
process just continues until the plan is
uh is approved if it's not approved the
previous plan is still in effect so you
know that's fine but it's it's sort of
becomes an empty bureaucratic exercise
in my in my you know estimation so uh
the enforceability mechanism in the
amendment is that uh you know after two
attempts they're they are no longer
allowed to proceed with rate rate making
uh rate changes so that you know
basically gums up the works to an extent
so it does require them to have a plan
an updated plan every five years on file
and I followup yeah thank you so my
followup would be around section 378 37
which is the first section of the bill I
know that there was some contention last
year about not losing that piece which
is basically a purpose statement right
um and so we left that in place and now
we've got several bills that attempt to
rewrite that piece so could you tell us
a little bit about uh how the language
of this piece came about because I
actually I like this language I like the
way it it covers um covers the piece
without pushing it in any One Direction
but um right I mean the difference
between the 378 37 uh as you see it in
this bill and the original language
which um there are there are a couple
differences I don't have I don't have
the original Statute in front of me
right now and I can tell you that you
know I received feedback from several
people who helped me write this and so
that you know it depends on on who who
who gave me some of the direction on
that but uh it does attempt
to uh I mean it it starts off with a
consideration of the financial stability
of the state's utility so that that is
the number one thing right off the bat
uh and it but it does provide for the
needs of the public as I said to receive
a service in a beneficial manner
including
uh uh cost effective Energy Efficiency
uh demand side uh resources that would
be distributed generation uh and
protection safety and health of citizens
fiscal environment and future supplies
of resources so it does attempt to wait
uh you know to carry out that balance
ing act so to speak of of the needs of
the utility to receive a guaranteed rate
of return and the needs of the of the
citizens to receive a service in a
beneficial manner including everything a
holistic kind of look at everything
environment Public Health uh and all
those sort of things thank you
representative Bernardi has a
question thank you Mr chair
uh represent Kaplan um uh at the very
bottom of the first page line 31
section four there's a requirement that
the plan include an assessment of
potential nonwired solutions for
electric distribution I I have no clue
what that might be could you explain
that a little further that's a great
question representative and I'm going to
defer to somebody coming after me
hopefully one of the uh expert witnesses
that will be up here at the table after
me will be able to answer that with more
pertinent and exact information than I
have Vice chair Thomas has a question
for you thank you Mr chair thanks for
taking my question just uh because this
bill seems to be all-encompassing did
you happen to confer with all of our
state utilities to get their to get
their input I did not confer with all of
them I conferred with ever
Source representative
followup um no I'll wait thank
you representative Harrington has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question I I read this
bill and it's sort of like wide open so
I guess I have two questions first do
you think that the Pu is not doing its
job and has to be directed by statute on
how to do it right and second having
seen this before when we had this
planning mode back some years ago when I
was on the commission it was like a wide
open season for anybody to come in and
challenge anything and they could go
after the because this bill has no
limits on it it seems like they could go
after anything is am I missing something
yeah I don't really see where you're
coming from I mean it seems like there's
pretty specific language about I mean
are you looking at the original bill or
the amendment because the the original
Bill does is a little bit more wide open
than the amendment the amendment is very
specific in terms of uh you know what uh
what the what details should be in the
plan and the the process by which the
plan is filed and uh the process by
which the public has input I mean do you
believe that the puc should not have
should not be required to be under any
kind of scrutiny I I don't think that's
really uh intended in in in the statutes
that set up the Public Utilities
Commission the reason we have laws the
reason we have regulations is because
it's a it's a Public Utilities
Commission overseeing a utility it's a
kind of a jury rigged cont Contraption
it's not purely Market base it's not
purely centralized planning it's kind of
a hybrid system it needs regulation and
so yeah I mean there there is a kind of
a a bureaucratic element to the process
I agree with you on that but it we
haven't come up with a better system we
need to have some kind of guard rail so
that the public has some weight on its
side and it's not just purely about the
current accounting for the for the
private company otherwise it's not uh
it's not you know we're not doing our
job of overseeing the public utility for
the benefit of the
public as we're not here to debate I
think appreciate your answer thank you
okay further questions uh for the
representative I have one for you uh
does your
legislation
estimate the costs that would be
incurred by the Pu to undertake these uh
Plan
reviews
and can you give us some idea of what uh
rape payers would end up having to pay
in order for these plans to be reviewed
by the
commission yeah I mean this is basically
a Manpower exercise and so what what the
Staffing requirements for the Pu in
order to carry this out I can't really
answer that question I think you should
really be asking the Pu there is no
fiscal note on this
so well as you I'm sure can surmise no
utility business could stay in Business
Without doing long range planning of the
sort that this legislation would
require so would you agree that it's
safe to assume that utilities are
already doing this planning
internally today no I disagree with you
representative with all due respect I I
don't think the utilities left to their
own devices would do long-term planning
uh to consider any sort of public
benefit in terms of the environment in
terms of Public Health uh if they
weren't required to do so if they if
it's not built into if it's not built
into their pricing structure in some
form or fashion their fiduciary duty to
their shareholders leaves them no reason
at all to consider a public benefit why
would they do it that's why we have to
have a a regulation like this in place
because it's not built into the current
system well since you mentioned that
I'll follow up with another question in
the original bill on line 28 it says
that an assessment of the plan's long
and short-term Environmental
and
economic and energy price impact on the
state is part of this plan isn't that
kind of outside the scope of
what a distribution plan would be all
about well not for a public utility uh
representative with all due respect I
mean the reason we have the reason it's
called a public utility is because it's
supposed to function uh in in benefit of
the public and the you know when you're
talking about short uh what is it long
and short-term environmental economic
and energy price impact I mean yeah the
energy price impact would be included in
any any any private company's plans but
not necessarily the long and short-term
environmental impact I don't
think I would think okay we we'll leave
it at that representative Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair um on line
12 you talk about the physical
environment and then on line 28 you just
talk about environment so are physical
environment and environment the same
thing and is there a legal definition of
physical environment Does it include
Wildlife water air and or
infrastructure okay line 12 the physical
environment of the State uh I am not
sure if there's a legal definition of
that but I would think that yes that
would Encompass all the things that you
mentioned
yeah thank you
additional questions representative
Harrington has one thank you thank you
for taking my question so just listening
to what you just said it I'm I'm
concluding then and I'm asking this as a
question you assume that the Pu is not
doing its job to take care of the
benefit Because unless they given
specific legislative Direction they
won't take into account environment
public good all this other stuff uh that
they're supposed to be taking in by
Statute already so you need to the
double down on it is that what we you're
saying I think that the that the
requirement of the utilities to file a
10-year plan is not only yes it it is a
a doubling down so to speak of the
statutory Authority the Public Utilities
Commission but it also gives the public
a process by which they can take part
and have some sort of impact and say in
what these plans should should include
and I I think that's a necessary thing
for for the public to have some
input additional questions for the
representative we have four more people
who would like to speak so I'd like to
move on if that's acceptable to the
committee and I would like to next call
on the New Hampshire Department of
energy represented by Mr
frons good morning Mr fron and welcome
to st& good to see you good to see you
two members of the committee my name is
Tom France I'm the director of
regulatory at the New Hampshire
Department of energy previous to that I
was with the Public Utilities Commission
for many many many years as director of
electric and at one point uh Chief
Economist the New Hampshire Department
of energy appreciates this opportunity
and we want to just clearly state that
we are not opposed to lease cost
planning
in general as a principle however we
don't think this bill is needed uh we
think it has faults and we do oppose
this bill for many of the same reasons
that we did for the lease cost uh
integrated resource plans last year uh
I'll start by saying that the standard
when it comes to regulations really is
safe reliable service atj and reasonable
rates
um there's a lot of things in here that
we already do we have
uh tremendous review of the
utilities Energy Efficiency programs
they're filed every three years uh
they're looked at they're basically set
out in statute for what the budgets are
as you well know and we take a close
look at those programs we do look at
Alternatives I want to be clear that uh
in a rate
case and it might be different if rate
cases were filed every 10 to 20 years
but we we seem to see rate cases that
are filed with the Public Utilities
Commission Now on about a 3 to four year
basis before
those changes and rates go into effect
and those capital projects are approved
we spend a lot of time and effort as do
others uh
including the
OCA looking at what those Al
alternatives are and whether or not the
utility chose the lowest cost lost for
the for the risk that was needed or for
the demand for that service whether it's
a
substation uh whatever that may be and
and a great example is what we did in
the recent testimony in the Liberty
Utilities uh electric
case so I think there's a lot of good
things that are uh intended by this
legislation I just don't actually think
they're needed and I think in some ways
they're duplicative and costly least
cost integrated resource plans that we
used to have often took well over a year
to for the Pu to adjudicate sometimes up
to 18 months um it took a tremendous
amount of resources from the Department
of energy I'm sure from the Pu and from
others to actually look at the plans
they evolved they changed and so that's
always been a concern we have
a resource constraint as everybody does
and we put a lot of resources into the
rate cases that are before us and as I
mentioned we have a gas and electric
utility rate case before uh the Pu right
now that we're deeply involved in uh we
expect to see another rate case possibly
two electric rate cases in 2024 and I
think that's the place that we need to
answer these questions look at the costs
and uh many of the things that are in
here we'll be taking a look at in those
cases so I respectfully uh appreci
appreciate the intent of this but want
to say that we the department of energy
does oppose it I also have a concern on
one area about the
amendment I haven't had time and we
haven't taken it back to look at but
when I hear
that
uh and we appreciate that it may have
teeth I I I do appreciate that but when
you say after a couple chances you
strike out and no changes in rates that
raises a red flag right away because
every 6 months default Service rates are
changing and I don't think that's a
great idea to not have default Service
rates change every six months because an
integrated resource plan uh hasn't been
approved thank you questions from the
committee repres uh Vice chair Thomas
has a question oh thank you Mr chair
thank you for taking my question um it
was inferred earlier in testimony
that it's only natural that Public
Utilities would not be after the public
interest um do you think that this bill
though with the things that are in it do
you think that would ensure more public
input and and put more teeth into the
utilities uh looking after public
interest I think in some ways this bill
would
actually perhaps read in the utilities
View and they can speak for themselves
uh view it as reducing their risk uh
I'll give you an
example it it goes back away
so have some patience with me when we
restructured the industry uh back in
1997 98 99 the order that came out from
the commission had to do with strained
cost and whether than not all the
utilities at the time of course were
vertically integrated uh met their
burdens and to reduce straining costs
and Connecticut Val electric company
which was a subsidiary of central
Vermont public service at the time the
puc's decision was that they should have
divested their purchase power agreements
with with Central Vermont Public Service
and therefore they were on the hook for
many many millions of dollars of
strained costs that the commission said
they their shareholders should actually
eat they took us to court um and I
participated in that we were also at the
firk and their one of their main
arguments was well the the decision that
the Pu made
here is unwarranted because they've seen
our lease cost plans every couple years
they've approved them they've understood
the planning process and therefore they
can't come back now and say that we
should have done this or done that that
should have been in the orders of the
puc as part of the lease cost integrated
resource plans at the time that were on
file so I think utilities uh often view
these as once those plans are approved
and legal people can argue about this
but certainly that was their main
argument at the time that these plans
protected them now again as as I've said
utilities should do good forecasting
utilities should look at Alternatives
utilities should be looking at things
that actually bring the same value to
their customers for the lowest cost
possible and and I think the best place
to do that is actually through a rate
case followup uh thank you for the
followup so are you saying that
um the Pu actually would be uh uh that's
part of the job is to look to see if the
utilities are working in the public
interest and doing all these four range
plannings when they when they do they
they review cases so would you see the
that's part of the puc's job anyway yes
okay representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chair thank you Mr France
for taking my question so um I notice
you know this is a a stab at replacing
what we lost with the LCP and trying to
sort of reinstate in statute
language
um that seem to be important in terms of
the process right to make sure that
somewhere it was covered what it is that
we would like out of integrated planning
and so it it doesn't say least cost here
while it does say cost considerations
are important and need to be part of the
formula so my question is I
I'm am I mistaken that this what is the
substance of um
the items that are detailed in the
amendment in terms of what would be in
statute for review that those do not
appear anywhere else in New Hampshire
statute at this
point I'm not sure they're in statute um
for example I don't
think I'd have to probably confer with
our attorneys but non- wires
Alternatives I'm not sure are in
statutes but they are certainly part of
a rate case uh because we'd sit there
and say and others should you know if
the utility could have brought the same
level of reliability or met certain
demand requirements for $100 but instead
spent
$150 that's not a very prudent decision
in our opinion and we would make that
case at the Pu and we have made those
cases at the Pu and then it's up to the
PC decide whether or not uh that was
based on the record and and if so they
should disallow anything above what the
actual cost should have been and would
have been prudently incurred to get the
same level of service reliability for
customers okay and followup followup
okay so then following that logical
conclusion um and understanding that a
lot of what is in here is is uh among
the
responsibilities of the doe and the Pu
as it is today would you be willing to
work to try and figure out how this
language could be uh amended by the time
we're going to be voting on this bill so
that it actually uh reflects the work
that is undertaken so that we actually
have something in statute that says what
we want it to say I'm happy to take that
back and confer with the commissioner
and Deputy Commissioner and and normally
we're more than willing to to work with
people on language thank
you representative Bernardi has a
question
thank you Mr chair uh so in the previous
testimony one of the key issues that
seems to be a driver for this uh
proposed bill is uh public input and so
I would like your assessment is the
public input that you see in this plan
somehow different than one would have in
public input in a rate case
somewhat yes um for a ray case and again
we have very competent attorneys behind
me uh and I'm sure Mr cre could answer
that
but for standing at a as part of a
proceeding you normally have to show
that you have a interest so that if it's
an lease cost plan or some kind of
distribution resource uh planning
process integrated distribution planning
I'm not sure you could normally
intervene in that if you lived let's say
in Lebanon and it was an eversource
integrated distribution plan uh
certainly in a rate case you'd have to
have a clear connection to the actual
docket and case and how you would be
affected and I would think that for
integrated distribution plan that would
also be the case although groups that
represent environmental interests that
are across the state or the region
they've often intervened and always that
I'm aware of been uh included in
proceedings so you have to show that you
have an interest that your members would
be affected and I think you'd be allowed
in the Pu historically has been pretty
inclusive in its
proceedings representative Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair um and thank
you for taking my question um you
testified that this bill covers a lot of
things that the Pu already does would it
not be best practiced to protect the
Integrity of that of those procedures
and
statute well I think they are basically
protected in statute for uh when it
comes to Safe reliable service adjust
and reasonable rates that uh authority
of the puc to determine that based on
the record I think a lot of those things
are there when you actually look at what
goes into a ray case and the kind of
testimony as well as all the uh data
requests responses I think you'd come to
the conclusion that many many of these
issues are certainly uh covered
comprehensively as part of a full rate
case followup yes thank you followup so
you just said that a lot of those things
are already there but just clarification
but not all correct probably not all um
thank you
yeah I mean there's a lot of again there
are there's a lot of useful information
and and and in my opinion it's in one
place when you actually look at a lease
cost plan or an integrated distribution
plan uh that's a document that many
people would find useful I don't deny
that it's a one it's almost like
One-Stop shopping you can pick it up and
you can see a lot of really useful
information uh in one one spot instead
of hunting for it but we do get filings
of the utilities uh and the p certainly
gets them as part of their requirements
as part of the public utilities
commission's rules as part of our rules
so there's a lot of information out
there I have a question for you do
utilities
typically include in a rate case
environmental and economic issues the
potential of non-wire solutions the
costs and benefits of grid
modernization those kinds of things show
up and
cases to some degree the answer to that
is yes but uh for example there may be
grid modernization issues in a rate case
that may make uh
customers more able to take care take on
some of the things that are of interest
to customers such as perhaps EV charging
or uh demand reductions on certain
circuits uh there could be battery is
storage that's part of a rate case those
things are all put of there but as far
as actually looking at specific
environmental
regulations uh we'll ask questions
perhaps about that but we're not first
and foremost either the Pu or the
department of energy environmental
Regulators so to follow up on that if
some of these issues are part of rate
cases what kind of an extra burden does
it add to the commission to evaluate
these uh
more amorphous uh questions and what
kind of an impact does that have on rate
payers well it's challenging um I just
said that we're not environmental
Regulators the Public Utilities
Commission is not an environmental
regulator um so I think it requires
additional resources and more time and
effort and probably some
more discipline as far as what exactly
or guidance in in uh the evaluation you
know there's might be a question of well
does this project or does this policy or
this program reduce emissions okay well
it may reduce emissions to what level
should it reduce emissions well if
there's not guidance there that's a
question what's the value of the avoided
emissions you know um some have markets
some don't lots of argument about what
those markets should be is the price of
CO2 $20 per ton avoided or is it $20 per
ton avoided those things you you you end
up in dockets that can have long
discussions arguments and and
uh really disputes about a lot of
environmental and economic issues that
I'm not sure that's the best place
before pu to do in general time is money
so is a longer docket cost more money to
adjudicate sure absolutely I mean
there's in some ways almost as much
resources go into
a resource planning docket as a rate
case depending on uh what's in it so
they can be very expensive then and and
time consuming okay thank you
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you Mr
France for taking my question you may
have just answered it but I really would
like to get some clarity here until last
year least cost integrated resource
planning was required so the Pu was
already evaluating those cases so can
you please explain the difference in
cost and effort uh between what the Pu
did have to do until uh that statute was
repealed versus what this statute this
bill would require well I think if you
look at those integrated resource plans
that the Pu did they took a very long
time some of them were outstanding for
over 18 months uh it there's an
opportunity costs so if you're spending
hundreds and hundreds of hours on an
integrated resource plan that's hundreds
of hours that you're not spending on
something else so unless you add more
resources or you're already
uh flush with resources which I don't
think the Pu would say they are and
certainly I don't think uh the
department of energy is that's things
that we're either going to have to hire
Consultants to do or something else gets
left behind for a while so it
it's opportunity costs are real costs
follow
up thank you but I was asking in
specifically about the difference
between what was done and what this bill
would do not not just the effort that
this bill would require but just what's
the what what is the incremental
difference if any between what was done
and what this bill would require thank
you for the clarification representative
and I'd have to say I'm not sure there
is
any a lot of the things uh similar in
this that were in previous uh
statute representative Harrington has a
question thank you chairman thank you
taking my question Tom um based on what
you just said and um it sounds like the
the bill uh if if it was to be Go full
would would need some guard rails right
now it's kind of like kind of fuzzy
protect the environment do all this good
stuff uh isn't that just a license to
litigate for certain you know
organizations that have three letters
that they go by uh they could tie this
PU up for months and months and months
and then they'd go to court on it and it
would just be litigation after
litigation is is that is without those
God Wills would that be happening that's
always a potential in any proceeding as
you know representative and uh we've
seen plenty of litigation and uh
integrated resource plans in the past uh
that's possible for any any any
proceeding and certainly this would be
no
different okay let's get the utilities
perspective thank you Mr France
appreciate you being here today thank
you let's get the utilities perspective
on this and ask Mike Lata from
eversource to give us his take on this
proposed
legislation good morning Mr
Lata good morning uh Michael Lata
representing eversource uh energy
appreciate the opportunity to testify
you before before you this morning um
eversource uh does support uh the
legislation as introduced uh I did have
an opportunity to uh see the amendment
previous uh earlier uh but I'm going to
focus my my comments on the bill that
was uh introduced and is before you
today um we believe that the legislation
represents a reasonable approach to
create a regulatory framework whereby
which utilities can present for review
and approval before the Pu their
long-term uh planning uh criteria and
plans um the bill requires that every
five years uh electric distribution
utilities uh file uh these long-term uh
integrated distribution plans uh they're
fairly straightforward um called for
under the bill I I think it's um uh I I
would say very consistent with the
utility planning that we're doing today
uh so a 10-year load
forecast uh several assessments of
various factors that might impact those
forecasts for example the Energy
Efficiency programs that are authorized
under other statutes the New Hampshire
safes programs um what we're seeing in
terms of uh demand response programs
that would have been previously approved
by uh the Public Utilities Commission uh
customer adoption of uh I'll say
industry trends that are are driving
customer adoption of various you know
whether it's heat pumps or
electrification of the the
transportation system uh and so really
this is is what utilities do from a
planning perspective uh today and so you
know it sort of begs the question why is
utility up here before you saying we're
good with with more
regulation um and I think you know Mr
France touched on on a number of the
areas quite frankly we see risk um
without a a planning framework uh
whereby we can present these Trends uh
let the commission let other
stakeholders know what we're seeing uh
from a a high level prior to a rate case
so if you think of of a rate case that's
really the utility has has already gone
out and and built infrastructure to meet
that customer demand so we've upgraded a
substation we've reinforced a a circuit
um and we're now bringing that uh into
the commission and seeking cost recovery
of those Investments that we've already
made um and so I think a lot of the
concerns that you heard from director
France about you know litigation risk or
open-ended or you know this will be a
lengthy exercise our fear is all of
those risks still exist they're just
pushed into the rate case and so we
would uh prefer a a a venue and and I
understand the concerns about open-ended
nature we we actually think that um this
is a reasonable approach but certainly
if if stakeholders would like to to work
on uh refinements we we welcome that uh
but we would prefer a a more uh orderly
proceeding uh that is is done uh in
advance of or or informing a future rate
case so you
know again why is the utility supporting
a bill with with more regulation because
we think that that the concerns raised
by uh the department of energy are real
uh and just get pushed into to another
venue um without uh without this
framework um and you know to answer the
question can't the commission do this
this today um as you heard there there
are bits and pieces and other um other
proceedings the Energy Efficiency
proceeding you know a lot of this uh in
rate cases um
but absent uh absent this bill the
utilities don't have um the ability to
offer a plan and the commission have
approval of that plan uh that H carries
some Force so um with that I'd be happy
to answer any questions that the
committee may have thank you appreciate
your test I have a couple questions for
you the first one is a couple of weeks
ago ever Source gave a presentation to
the New Hampshire transport ation
Council and during the course of that
presentation it indic
indicated and showed a slide about its
integrad distribution planning process
so it's clear that you already do this
process and my question would be if
you're already doing this process and
you could certainly share that plan with
the Pu why do we need legislation of
this
nature thank you for the question and uh
just
by way of background um we did give a
presentation to the uh New Hampshire
transmission uh Transportation sorry uh
Transportation Council uh at their
request uh they were interested in how
customer adoption of electric vehicles
was in impacting our utility planning
and I I just start off by saying we
would very much welcome the opportunity
to provide um a similar presentation to
this committee I I think um it would be
quite uh quite helpful in the context of
this um so absent uh a statutory
framework like the one that is um uh
considered as part of hb1
1431 there isn't that venue for us to
provide that plan and have an
adjudicative proceeding to review that
plan have stakeholders as with any
adjudicative proceeding um if they have
standing engage in that obviously the
cons conser Advocate the department of
energy being uh uh two of them and then
have approval of that plan uh so absent
this framework there really isn't that
mechanism where the commission can say
the legislature has has told us to
review and and render judgment on these
plans which again helps
inform uh uh future uh decisions of the
utility and cost recovery of
infrastructure
Investments well my follow-up question
would be who plan is this and the reason
I asked that plan if you look in the on
page two of the
legislation on line five it says the
commission shall either approve reject
or modify the
plan the commission can modify the plan
it's not your plan is it the
commission's plan so so uh I think this
is fairly consistent with um how the Pu
can SU conducts uh its proceedings where
the utility makes a filing whether it's
a rate case whether it's uh an Energy
Efficiency filing the commission will
review that they could say nope throw
the whole thing out or yes this is the
best thing we've ever seen or we approve
this with the following stipulation so
uh so certainly the commission um based
upon the record that's in front of them
uh the testimony that's provided the
data requests that are provided uh could
say
uh offer uh suggestions on on
changes so did I understand you to say
that maybe the language of the bill
should say the commission shall either
conditionally approve or reject the
plan uh it could read approve
conditionally approve or or uh or or
reject I mean I i' have to take that
back and review it with the
team okay thank you additional questions
from the committee representative McGee
has a question had a question let's see
okay my question is around uh the
difference in what an integrated uh
distribution planning requirement gets
at which is that there are a lot of
moving pieces right now in how utilities
are operating um in terms of being able
to contract uh being able to participate
in the in the wholesale markets being
able to um help us create new
infrastructure and also supporting the
distribution system so my question is
whether there is value in requiring an
integrated distribution plan for that
purpose for the purpose that um I think
what we're asking is that that holistic
planning that you're doing behind the
scenes that there is some requirement
and oversight for saying how are all
these pieces fitting together in order
to create a public utilities product
that is in the best interest of the
consumer yeah and maybe that would be a
question for Mr GRE as well but sure at
the end of the day um and I very much
agree with uh director France what we're
what we're seeking to achieve here is a
safe reliable system that meets our
customers needs at the lowest cost and
and so you know long-term planning is is
a critical component of that and it's
sort of one step in the process it is
not uh the end of the process by by any
stretch you know approval of these plans
does not relinquish the obligation of
the utility to continue to evaluate um
alternatives to to make the best
decisions present those decisions and
defend them as part of a raid case um
but this is a a higher level look at
broader Trends um in terms of what our
customers are choosing the
infrastructure that's required to to
meet um uh those choices and you know
the costs and implications of that and
so you know I do want to point out that
this is a a distribution plan it's not a
generation plan uh it's not a
transmission plan uh those are areas
obviously as as a restructured utility
we don't own generation resources uh
transmission planning is something that
is done uh subject to F jurisdiction at
the regional level um but looking at
that broader you know what are the
different factors that in impact the
development of the distribution system
and the ab and the ability of the
utility to to offer a safe reliable
system that meets customers needs we we
think that that's uh an appropriate
framework representative Harrington has
a question thank you and thank you for
taking my question um I was going to ask
something different but I get to start
with this one because what you just said
I'm reading off of the bill it says
submission of integrated electric
distribution and transmission plans and
you just stated it doesn't include
transmission so I I'm uh keeping my
focus on the bill as introduced not the
amendment I believe the amendment uh
calls in in uh transmission which is
something that would be a concern for us
because of the jurisdictional issues
okay in followup followup okay in both
of them they they have a thing that it
says that um it's the New Hampshire
energy policy to make sure that future
supplies of resources are taken into
consideration and the plan has to
address that as one of the criteria how
would a utility electric utility in New
Hampshire have to weigh in on future
supply of resources I don't know if is
natural gas oil wind solar offshore wind
coal I
mean how how could you possibly do that
so I I I think um the future supplies of
resources
uh is the reference in
378 uh 37 the New Hampshire energy
policy
which I have to compare to existing
statute but but that is I think either
consistent with or or currently existing
statute um and so it does say that the
plan needs to be consistent with uh that
as part of the plan there needs to be an
assessment uh of the consistency with
the energy statute um uh but you know
that is a broad overarching statement
and clearly we we don't own generation
resources we as the committee well knows
and you representative we we go to the
market the market gives us uh what we
get so so I I think that that's existing
um uh in the existing
law representative Bernardi has a
question thank you Mr chairman uh so uh
Mr Lotti you offered to present uh the
information you presented to the
transportation committee um I would be
interested in to know if you can then
when you
present uh your expected uh uh
development needs in on the distribution
side if it could be divided or is
divided into this is what we need to do
to maintain the current system all the
old stuff how do we keep it working
working this is what we need to do to
add to the system for growth in
population and this is what we need to
do to add to the system to cover
EVs and this is what we need to do to
add to the system to cover heat pumps
are those categories of growth and cost
available in your plan or could they be
yeah I'll have to
so very much appreciate the opportunity
to have the folks who actually put
together these plans and and do the
forecasting uh come in and and talk
about how they do
that electrification of the
transportation system electrification of
the the heating um sector those are
inputs and criteria that we we consider
as part of our planning and I I think
they could speak to how they impact our
load and the infrastructure um required
in order to meet that that additional
usage so I I think they could speak to
that yes thank
you we have two more people who would
like to testify on this bill and we're
running up against the time constraint
here so um does anybody really need to
ask another question of Mr
M okay thank you appreciate you being
here
next up is kather MCC M
mccor sorry from the New Hampshire
Sierra
Club and I'd really appreciate it uh if
you could keep your remarks as succinct
and brief as possible
please thank you um thank you for
allowing me to speak I understand we are
over time
already um but I have a handout um to uh
highlight the different uh topics uh to
introduce myself my name is Katherine
corkery uh think of County Cork and
County k um or County Carry uh I
represent New Hampshire Sierra club and
uh we that is about 10 uh I'm sorry
15,000 people in the state and um we
support the the spirit of the bill um
and the promise to reinstate the
planning process uh to support rate
payer accountability
transparency economic Justice for the
current law for just and reasonable
rates that's RSA 37
8.8 um additions to the bill that uh
Sierra Club uh believes that could
strengthen uh the pursuit to reinstate
planning the planning process based on
these these four principles but uh I do
want to highlight that the planning
process is before they spend the money
and the rate case is after they spend
the money that is a really important
piece
um uh so uh the first principle if it
looks like a
duck it's a duck um the plan should
include all the all of the
expenditures uh to improve to upgrade to
maintain to expand to reroute the
infrastructure network of poles and
wires and Transformers and
pipelines and um all of the energy
infrastructure exam uh to must be
vigorously examined by the puc for rap
paers continued service transparency and
confidence confidence we need to have
confidence in the spending of our
utilities and a way to do that is to
have a plan that people can look at and
have one place to see it before they
spend the money
um no one left behind principle all so
this bill only includes Electric
utilities as introduced this should
include all energy utilities Gas and
Electric right now that's all we have um
but we should it should be all of them
uh with the same planning procedures um
as we did
before uh all utilities have large
construction project plans we heard and
and I I believe Mr Vose the chairman was
talking about all the internal planning
that utilities do it it in fact happens
um and that planning process must be
made clear to rate payers to the
residents of the State uh in an
accessible transparent manner to provide
the entire picture prudency must be
paired with accountability to allow the
state agencies to impose to veto or
adjust these utility plans um to ensure
prudence and just and reasonable
costs um f is for
functional uh utilities are planning all
the time and um they don't wait they
don't sit there and say oh is it 10
years let's do that plan
they are planning in real time and um
the planning procedure should be
functional um should be meaningful to
the utilities and to ratee payers uh it
is not in the best interest of residents
utilities Regulators or or the
businesses of the state to wait until a
complaint is filed or after a project is
constructed in a rate case to determine
if the project costs were prudent just
and reasonable you don't do that
afterwards and the last is all cost is
all cost the federal jurisdiction
includes Interstate transmission into
the wholesale Market the states have exu
exclusive jurisdiction over the
transmission of into the retail Market
so that's how they're
differentiated by the where the
electricity is going if it's going into
the wholesale Market or if it's going
into the retail
Market all of these expenditures that
that get passed on to rate payers from
the wholesale or the retail transmission
projects either gas or you electric must
be rigorously audited and determined to
be prudent and just and reasonable by
the
Pu otherwise it doesn't
happen currently the state is allowed to
engage in federal proceedings they're
allowed to do that they are not
restricted from the discussions at
firk this bill must require that the
state participate in federal proceedings
to protect rap
payers there are billions of dollars at
stake that are currently not being
examined and thank you very
much okay questions for M
Corry seeing none I'd like to call the
last speaker on this bill and that is
Nick cof of the conservers and law
foundation and I have passed out his
written
testimony and I'd ask you to be as brief
as possible of course uh good morning
chairman and and other committee members
I'll be as brief as possible I'm Nick
cof from the conservation law Foundation
based here in conquered um you know
we've heard a lot of testimony this
morning and there's no other
comprehensive planning that's occurring
outside of the integrated resource
planning process you know this is what
was happening before the statute was
repealed and you know some of this
planning does you know sure does occur
during rate cases but you know that's
very very small piece of all the plan
elements that can occur and under New
Hampshire law there's currently no
requirement for the Public Utilities
Commission to look at the public health
um impacts the environmental impacts um
any any diversity benefits that could
result from utility planning there's no
other requirement in New Hampshire law
and so that that's certainly not
occurring in um in raid cases or any
place else um same same goes with
respect to grid modernization sure you
know in um in rate cases you kind of get
bits and pieces of that you know there
might there might be um some sort of
peripheral consideration of those things
but there there's no holistic or
comprehensive docket where the Public
Utilities Commission is considering grid
modernization how do we build the grid
of the future um obviously electricity
demand is changing and there's no other
comprehensive um docket where we're sort
of considering how to how how to meet
those changes in the
future
um you know same same with respect to um
to non-wire Solutions um sure you know
there there's there's some con minor
consideration and raid cases but there's
not really a holistic docket where where
the Public Utilities Commission is
considering what sort of non-wire
solutions can we can we um you know put
forth that might obviate the need for
some of these expensive substation or
distribution line Investments there's a
question before what what are non-wire
solutions well that's de demand
reduction measures that's and energy
storage there's just no docket anywhere
else where there's or proceeding
anywhere else where they're considering
all all these different
considerations um and then you know I I
agree with um the amendment that this
should also apply to to gas planning as
well the gas planning is just important
it's currently not in the amendment as
it's in the bill as proposed um you know
there there's there's needs to to
applies to gas planning it can
significantly reduce costs and make sure
that we're spending money on the the
lease cost option rather than more
expensive options um and finally in in
the bill as proposed you know as has
been recognize there's no there's no um
consequence to failure to have this plan
approved and so there there needs to be
some sort of consequence if um if the
plan is not approved long long story
short we we can't we cannot have this
post talk um process in rate cases where
um the Public Utilities Commission
considers for the first time if what the
utility is doing is right and in the
best interests of of um New Hampshire we
need a spot check initially before they
go and spend those Investments to make
sure that what they're doing is in the
best interest of the state um and so
that's why public um integrated resource
planning was very important before the
repeal and why we need to reinstate
these requirements for New Hampshire I'm
happy to take any
questions
okay uh representative Harrington has a
question thank you and thank you for
taking my question you mentioned two
things I'm trying to get straight you
said that the Pu or the utility I guess
in combination should take into account
uh in the environment in diversity now
we have specific laws dealing with the
environment and that's but those are are
done by Dees enforces those so are you
saying that the Pu should go above and
beyond those and what do you mean by
saying they should plan for diversity in
this plan and who's going to pay for and
I mean my my diversity I mean diversity
of of resources not diversity of
personnel or anything like that what I
mean is you know are they you know are
we not putting all of our eggs in one
basket are we are we investing only in
one you know in one fuel source um or
you know what are we only um buying from
one fuel source in the case of electric
utilities you know which which places
you know which makes rirs exposed to
volatile volatility in in uh the type of
fuel and with respect to um you know the
question about the environment sure it's
DS's um job to to sure that
environmental regulations are being
complied with
but you know that the state energy
policy is more than just cost it's more
than just whether where rates are just
and
reasonable 378 37 currently you know it
it it brings into account a lot of
different factors to make sure utility
spending is in the is in the public
interest and you know where where these
where these utilities are heavily
regulated by
Design I think I think we need to think
it more broadly about whether what
utilities are doing is in the public
interest not just whether it's going to
cost you know the costs are just and
reasonable but whether you know what
what the planning is doing is good for
the environment is good for it's good
for the public health of the state it's
good for um you know it's not going to
um result in volatility for prices for
rate
payers representative Ros has a question
thank you Mr chairman thanks Nick for
being here um I want to you mentioned
the non- wirus Alternatives in your um
testimony I just want to give you
another chance to speak about that um
one thing
or yeah one thing that's happening a lot
out we know out there anecdotally and
you know
reading the media there's a lot of
customers investment individual
homeowners and businesses are investing
in things like behind the meter
generation
solar behind the meter storage um load
man even load management even at the
residential level but certainly at um at
the business level in your opinion is
there a
way
that
the in utility rate cases as you point
out they're they're looking at you know
post Hawk um evaluation of utility
Investments but is there way for the the
without integrated resource planning for
U utilities to account for and value the
kind of customer side Investments that
are being that are being made I mean I I
think there's no sort of integrated
process that's occurring you know in in
rate cases so and the Liberty um
utilities you know Liberty electric
docket Liberty is proposing a battery
storage it and so you know that that's
kind of that does that does get to to
some of those um issues but there's no
sort of comprehensive or integrated
process whereby utilities are looking at
you know can we can we use you know
behind the meter front of the meter
storage whatever you know to for
reliability benefits for resiliency
benefits that there's not this
comprehensive process that's occurring
where where they're doing that you know
before they make these Investments and
so I would argue that in order to
modernize our grid we we need we need
that process you know before they go and
make these
expenditures representative thas has a
question thank you Mr chair um and and
thank you for being here Mr kof and
answering my question um previous people
have testified that this bill would open
up a lot of
litigation um several people have said
that I'm not a lawyer um however you are
thank you um don't can you answer this
question don't you have to have a legal
and legitimate reason to begin any
litigation and wouldn't any legal
challenge in this process be
appropriate absolutely I mean
um you know I've I've been an intervener
in some of these integrated resource
planning cases in the past
and anytime that I'm you know arguing
that utility hasn't done their job it's
you know because you know there there's
a legal basis for it or you know I find
that there's a legal basis for it so and
that you know I don't think this is a
recipe for for Vol um that's going to
open the floodgates for for litigation I
mean you know there there's the
utilities and the Public Utilities
Commission have had Decades of
experience with these with these um
processes and for you know I'm I'm not
really aware of a um the Public
Utilities Commission ever denying one of
these um plans so really it's just an
opportunity to do a spot check on some
of the planning and and maybe make some
improvements so that we can ensure it's
in the best interest of the state thank
you okay so our our last speaker on this
bill is M
friedricks representing 350.org and
because we're running up against some
severe time restraints I'm going to have
to restrict you miss Fredick to three
minutes maybe you could ask your
question of the next
person
uh my name is m friedricks um and I'm uh
here with 350 NH um and I just wanted to
share a little bit of some of what I
have heard from other energy bills um
that were being heard before the Senate
which is um that several businesses um
you know major manufacturers major
Employers in New Hampshire shared their
frustration with the New Hampshire
regulatory environment because they had
made major Investments um in solar for
example on their facilities and also in
um load management and in battery
storage and their frustration was that
um there wasn't a great sense of how
these resources were being incorporated
into the state's energy planning and
therefore made it very difficult for the
businesses to understand um and plan
economically and so um to representative
Reynold's um question
um you know our big concern is that um
without having some sort of stability
and planning it makes it very different
difficult from an economic environment
and it makes New Hampshire less
competitive economically because
businesses can't take into consideration
what sort of benefits may come from the
utilities um should they plan for their
their energy system is there validity
and planning for that energy storage to
be available back to the Grid or should
it only be considered in terms of um
that energy storage being available for
that business to use as needed and so
we're really already hearing from our
business community that the lack of
planning in this area makes it a more
difficult environment in which to make
business decisions and it's not only um
you know businesses but um yes at the
smaller scale uh individual consumers
and certainly towns um and so you know
working um um and serving My Town um of
Durham uh one of the things we we have
been discussing and examining for
example is battery storage and it's
important for us to understand the
incentives that may be there down the
future in order to understand what the
municipality should be investing in um
for our own energy costs um and I'm
happy to you know try and answer any
questions um certainly from a you know
less technical standpoint but um
hopefully that my testimony is helpful
in terms of being able to share what
I've heard from businesses and what I
know that our own town is considering
thank you representative parshall has a
question no okay no questions thank you
very much for coming to testify and with
that we'll close the public hearing on
House Bill
1431 and open a public hearing on House
Bill
dfn relative to studies of nuclear
energy Technologies and I ask the prime
sponsor to uh introduce this legislation
to us good morning Representative Keith
Ammon thank you Mr chair and uh for the
record my name is Keith Ammon from
Hillsboro District
42 and I represent the towns of New
Boston Mount Vernon and
lineboro and I'm before you today to
introduce House Bill
1465 relative to studies of nuclear
energy Technologies I'll give you just a
little bit of background in uh
2022 a bill was passed that came through
this committee House Bill
543 that created the study commission
for advanced uh nuclear
technology and uh one this bill is one
of the recommendations of that commi
that commission
report so I I brought one to show you
here um and I also have copies that I'll
leave in the committee room for the
entire committee uh it's a 50-page
report and it includes another 50 pages
of meeting minutes so we held uh
meetings for a year last year most of it
uh where we invited different Advanced
nuclear uh manufacturers to come and
present uh to our commission uh along
with uh Federal regulatory bodies and
some other industry experts and I want
to recognize that representative
Harrington was the vice chair of that
Commission and I know representative
Doug Thomas uh came to many of the
meetings if uh if you'd like to find out
more about that commission and to people
listening at home it's nuclear. energy
is the easiest way but it's also
available on the state's
website so uh with that um in our
research for the commi for the
commission we stumbled upon existing
statutes and I printed that out for you
it is um
chapter 162b of our
rsas and I printed out for you the
existing statute so this is already law
and this is what the bill attempts to
update um and I want to point out in
existing law I'd like to point out just
two aspects of existing law on the first
page at the
bottom uh RSA 162
B3 it says conduct cond conduct of
studies concerning changes in laws and
regulations with a view to Atomic
Industrial Development
and it says that each of the following
agencies shall
regularly study atomic energy and it it
lists the Department of Health and Human
Services the Department of Labor the
Department of
Transportation the Public Utilities
Commission and the department of energy
I'm reading on the back of the of the
second
page uh and the Department of
Insurance the Council on resources and
development so already an existing
statute uh and I believe this law is
something like 60 years old believe it
or not that these departments are
supposed to regularly conduct studies of
atomic
energy um and if I turn your attention
to section 162
B4 it talks about the appointment of one
of the state departments the head of one
of the state state departments concerned
as the as adviser to the governor with
respect to Atomic Industrial Development
and this position has a name it's the
coordinator of atomic development
activities and that's 162 B4 section
Roman num
4 so so this is existing statute that
goes back to uh the atomic the birth of
the atomic age and it's being
ignored uh what little research we could
uncover this position of atomic energy
coordinator hasn't been filled since
something like 2007 and the person
listed last to fill it is has since
passed unfortunately so we can't ask him
any questions um so uh that was
interesting you know looking through our
state statutes so the bill
1465 I'm going to just highlight three
aspects of it one is simple uh simple
updating of
terminology we we use nuclear a lot more
than we use Atomic these days so uh and
we have the the nuclear Regulatory
Commission
federally uh not the atomic energy
commission right that we no longer call
it that um and so some aspects of the
bill are just updating terminologies
just so we we don't seem like we're in
the stone ages regarding this uh
statute the second aspect and it's on
page three line 19 is a very uh it it's
very small but it it's a it packs a
punch that is to High our state statutes
to the federal definition of advanced
nuclear and this was a recommendation
from uh Christine I'm GNA say her name
wrong but chis media Christine chis
media from the nuclear energy Institute
who was uh paying attention to our
meetings and she said that uh it's a
good idea to to Anchor your state
statutes to the federal definition of of
advanced atomic
energy and I print that out for you in
that in that three-page print out the
last page has the federal definition
it's right in the middle of the page
there's a section definitions and it
says Advanced nuclear reactor so this
would tie our state statutes to that
definition and uh you know with any
amendments uh
occurring um excuse me Mr
chairman here over here Ms is is there a
handout because we haven't gotten it
down at this end
I've seen one handout it's um it's this
that's yeah that's the one I'm referring
to star cube uh I printed out starcube
I'm not affiliated in any way with star
cube other than they paid attention to
our commission and it turns out and I'll
get to that in a moment but let me St
track
here apparently it hasn't made its uh uh
I 20 copies to the rest of
us
it's just a h a print out of existing
statute yeah there's two two and there
was a and there was a letter yes
correct I'm pretty sure everybody got
the letter but not everybody got
the copy of chapter
162b thank you and I'm sorry I
interrupted it's okay that's all right
all right representative Ammon continue
please okay so first first thing the
bill does is update some outdated
definitions or uh terminology actually
second thing it does is ties our state
statutes to the federal definition of
advanced nuclear and I printed all that
out for you and then the last thing it
does is this atomic energy coordinator
position that was supposed to be
appointed and advised the governing
Council and the governor and it hasn't
been filled so it takes that it sort of
resurrect that position because it's
already in statute puts it under the
opes of the Department of energy uh and
then it requires the department of
energy to sort of be be the appoint
someone to be the
coordinator and it gives uh because
there's there were no deadlines I think
that that might be why the statute was
being ignored so I put a deadline in
there of five years uh that the report
would be issued once every five years
and I'm that that can uh that was just
an arbitrary number number if it makes
sense to make that something different
I'm open to that um I had a thought
since filing that the uh Department of
energy does issue the 10-year energy
plan document that's quite extensive and
they're required to do that once every
three years so maybe it makes sense to
sort of make that part of the package of
of that but I'll leave that up to the
committee
um so Advanced nuclear uh it's on the
horizon it might be distantly on the
horizon depending on uh which which news
uh we get of the day uh we know that uh
new scale was a big hope in Utah uh and
that
recently uh that that project fell apart
new scale is continuing on as as a
company um I believe that this
technology is going to come it's going
to be it's going to be clean it's going
to be firm power uh and it's going to be
uh scalable where it can be one
megawatts all the way up to 300
megawatts there are currently something
like 42 different companies currently
working in the advanced nuclear space
they have hired something like 14,000
employees and they're spending in the
order of9 billion dollar developing
Advanced nuclear um Westinghouse is one
of the companies and we know
Westinghouse has a manufacturing
facility in New Hampshire in Newington
New Hampshire they actually manufacture
components for nuclear reactors um so I
won't dive into the study commission
report because I'll leave copies for you
in the room um but you can see that
there's there's opportunity here for our
state to be uh sort of on the Leading
Edge of advanced nuclear and this bill
is not very ambitious it's kind of a
little bit of a housekeeping bill um but
it is to like move the ball forward and
and let you know uh make sure that our
state and its departments are paying
attention to to this
development I think that's all I have oh
one more thing uh we we found out about
this company Manchester based company
called starcube I printed out their I
think I think this was emailed to you
and I was cced on it I think that's how
I got it yes it was um they were hoping
to be here today but the weather uh kept
them from coming and I think they have
additional comments that they'd like to
present but this is an example of
uh you know instate
development uh in this industry and uh
it it's something I think this committee
uh you know would would do well to pay
attention to
so thank you happy to take any questions
okay thank you questions for the
representative representative Corman has
one thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative Ammon uh for that
presentation um I have to confess I was
a little too lazy to look up us codes
16271 B1 about Advanced nuclear reactors
I printed it out for you if you have it
in front of you you did yep and there
are copies coming okay there's the last
page of that packet has it um oh I see
it in the middle of the page there's
those definitions it's right below that
okay
yeah in that case um I don't have a
question all right so what was your
question would it would have been um can
you uh give us a brief description of an
advanced nuclear
reactor yeah um the definition is the
best way to to deal with it but um an
advanced nuclear reactor um so there's
something called generation three
reactors which is what this is going to
take a while which is what seab Brook is
right it's a it's a light Water Reactor
um but there are Advanced versions of
that they're they're called Generation 3
plus and one of the big Innovations is
they have safety features that prevent
vent uh meltdown and the absence of all
power failure so Generation 3 plus um
Westinghouse has one that's based on the
the same design that vogle is but it's
much smaller 300 megawatts and then
generation four are Rea Advanced
reactors that have uh they use something
called Trio fuel which is like a like a
pebble or like a billiard ball a whole
bunch of them that they're bathed in gas
usually helium and the gas is the the
conduit for uh the heat exchange um
that's one it could also be molten salt
instead of helium um and these are also
very safe that if all the power if
something like Fukushima happened where
the generators that were required to
keep it running got flooded with water
and couldn't operate that the system
would shut down very safely into a
dormant State and that's uh that's one
of the the the uh inherit uh features
additional questions representative muns
has
one thank you Mr chair and thank you for
presenting this bill
um qu question for you um currently and
and I think the way you're envisioning
this moving forward is that each of
these individual departments produces
their own
report um would you what what what are
your thoughts on instead of having them
each produce an individual report have
Doe
kind of get get input from each of them
and produce a single
report yeah I I think that's pretty much
how it's that's the way I understand it
um and again this is existing statute
this is supposed to already be being
done and and it hasn't been for a while
so I would see I would Envision instead
of the atomic coordinator the atomic
activities coordinator that that would
be a position in in the doe and they
would coordinate just like they were you
know it was supposed to back in the day
uh with all those other departments
because atomic energy does touch many
different aspects it touches the labor
force it touches Supply chains it
touches Transportation it touches
Insurance it touches Health and Human
Services the environment right so uh
those departments would be uh you know
consulted with for the report generation
follow followup followup
um thank you for that answer but I I
guess what I was suggesting and I just
wanted to get your thought your reaction
was changing the statute so that it says
it's it's going to be a single report
produced by the coordinator okay with
input from yeah those other departments
I'm I'm open to that uh to make it
explicit that would be fine okay yeah
thank you representative liwicki has a
question um thank you Mr chairman thank
you representative um is there a
realistic path forward for New Hampshire
to actually have more nuclear
generation a realistic
path um yes but I think it's going to
take time just because uh the the
industry moves very
slowly um the path would be would
require private
Capital uh to come in and to to back
stop uh development because we're not a
we're not a a vertically integrated
Market representative Harrington can
tell you were a uh you know deregulated
Market um but that private capital is
out there there there's billions of
dollars being invested in this industry
right now um and so if our state is
welcoming to the industry and our
Regulators are knowledgeable and paying
attention to it uh that's where that
Capital would pay attention it it
currently is um so with our commission
we've pretty much touched a lot of these
different manufacturers they're all
aware that New Hampshire is paying
attention to this industry so that's how
I would see it playing out is the the
funding of it
um there are other recommendations in
the report that I won't get into
but representative Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chair um on the bottom of
page one going on to page two you talk
about um a person needs to obtain a
license or permit from the United States
nuclear Regulatory Commission
um to engage in activities um how do you
know how easy or difficult it is to
obtain such a license and are we going
to see a prolifer a proliferation of
backyard
nuclear
devices yeah
um one can only dream that we'd all have
a nuclear reactor in our backyard um so
the the bill language that you just
cited is existing law the only change
the bill makes is it changes it from the
atomic energy commission to the nuclear
Regulatory Commission so that's already
existing law okay um and uh and again
I'll defer to representative Harrington
he's an expert in this field but the NRC
is looking to uh create uh regulatory um
regulatory framework for advanced
nuclear and I think I think new scale uh
was actually licensed by the NRC that
was one of the the the hopeful uh you
know events that that happened in that
regard okay thank you representative
Harrington has a question yeah thank you
thank you for taking my question I'm I'm
I understand the uh housekeeping aspect
of the bill but is it is this going to
be uh other duties as assigned or is it
going to be a new position as this
coordinator because I mean realistically
you know when I hear the uh head of uh
dup power's nuclear division say they
want to put in maybe 10 gaw of nuclear
but they don't expect to build anything
for five to 10 years because they don't
want to be first they're a vertically
integrated utility that has a big
nuclear Fleet why would anybody come to
New Hampshire in the future within the
next 5 to 10 years so will we pretty
mature with this yeah so the bill it's a
5-year cycle so previously these reports
were supposed to be issued I think by
anually that that was uh the original
that that's existing statute so this uh
puts it out once every five years I
think
uh some kind of frequency like that once
every five years where we're paying
attention to an industry that we know is
you know it's it's Fe it's a feasible
industry it's just the regulation uh
aspect is what's kind of slowing it down
and we know that I mean we've heard from
the dep Department of energy they they
actually came to our commission that
there's a big push for advanced nuclear
currently at the federal level so you
know this is just my imagination but the
way I would see it playing out is the
first of a kind reac actors will
probably probably be built in South
Korea or in Poland right and that'll
prove the design uh for you know anth of
a Kind which is really what we would
need to get to for New Hampshire to uh
for it to be Fe feasible in New
Hampshire um just to follow up I just
when you follow
up the I just want to get the intent of
the bill is not to create a new position
but it would be somebody that's already
in the department of energy and it would
be other d as assigned and this would be
their other
duties that's the way I would I would
see it I I'll leave it up to the
Department of energy to to you know
maybe this needs to be tweaked um but
what I don't want to have happen is a
statute that everyone's ignoring about
the subject right like let's let's
repeal the statute if we're not going to
do anything else right um but I think it
makes sense to sort of you know breathe
some new life into this and uh you know
this is my first attempt and it's the
committee's bill at this point so all
right so let's talk about the elephant
in the room and that is the fiscal note
which says that this bill will cost
hundreds of thousands of dollars to
implement the changes in this bill
because of all the new positions that
that will be required do you think those
estimates are realistic I you know can I
uh can we like laser focus in on one of
them because I almost fell out my chair
when I read it um the the Department of
Business and economic Affairs their
fiscal note was way outside what the
other departments were saying um they
want a whole new position
so the Department of Business and
economic Affairs would play a cameo role
in this once every fiveyear report
right how would you require a new
position that gets paid it was 120
$121,000 wor benefits every year so that
you could
participate with you know a few pages in
the report you know I'm not trying to
diminish the the position of the
department but I I think that one fiscal
note there is way outside the norm the
other departments mainly said that they
can handle it with existing resources
the department of energy of course would
have the most responsibility and uh I I
would pay attention more to their their
needs
than hiring a new employee at 121,000 a
year so okay good thank you rep Vice
chair Thomas has a question thank you Mr
chair thank you for taking my question
um
I assumed since this was a
recommendation from the commission that
everybody on the commission was in favor
of this bill or of of what you submitted
yeah so the report was was unanimous um
and uh this was one of the
recommendations in the report so so so
my question basically is if we just if
we do this bill there might be some
tweaking required but if we do this bill
which is basically to do what we should
have been doing all along yeah um it
seems to me that that it would
um bring to light the proper education
that would be needed within the state
and therefore the general public as to
the the the benefits of looking in the
far future of what the new type of
nuclear energy could be is is this is
this what the intent of of this bill
would bring to the table a a a new
education to get rid of the old obsolete
um idea that that nuclear is bad but
that the new technology is actually good
it's the cleanest form we have for for
sustainable type energy is would that be
intent would that intent be met by this
bill I believe so I believe so that's
uh again it's it's existing statute
that's being ignored so we should do
something and I this was my my best
attempt at at uh you know kind of
keeping the ball rolling from our
commission so representative muns has a
question another question thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my second
question um other other than adding the
definition of advanced nuclear
reactor
um I don't I don't see any place in the
bill where it you know talks about or
directs the state agencies to to
specifically look at that technology am
I am I missing something uh just give me
one minute and I'll I'll try to find the
answer to your
question I I guess while you're doing it
as a followup or is it just the the hope
that they will look at
look it should be assigned to the
Department of
energy I'm just my glasses
aren't so my reading of this is on page
two line 8 each of the following
departments and agencies of the state
government is directed to initiate and
to pursue continuing studies as to the
need if any for changes in the laws
administrative rules administered by it
that would arise from the presence blah
blah blah is that
basically what you're directing I'm
having trouble finding it and I
apologize but the intent was to put that
to add that to the duties of the
Department of energy and maybe
there's it was such a simple change that
maybe I missed it but just a
clarification I mean I was I was I was
asking if there's if there's anything in
the bill that specifically says that
advanced
nuclear um reactors should be looked
at and I'm trying to find the answer so
in the in the draft that I sent to OS it
had the department of energy would have
that particular responsibility not not
necessarily the under the other
departments I'm just having trouble
finding it and uh I found it you sorry
yep line page two line 18 new paragraph
continuing studies Department of energy
Advanced nuclear reactors there we go my
apologies so I wasn't uh blowing hot air
okay good thank you all right additional
questions representative McGee has one
yeah thank you um representative Ammon
for taking my question and for putting
forth the bill I think it's a it's a
good idea um on the amount here that
that uh the Department of Business and
economic Affairs is putting in here I
think maybe they're assuming that they
have to hire somebody that has a little
bit of experience in order to contribute
the part that they might need to
contribute because you're you're asking
for a fairly comprehensive look right so
these people are going to have to know
something yeah I would think about the
industry could
be um and maybe they're resource
strapped because uh they had a seat on
the study commission and and and didn't
participate so oh that's yeah that's
common yeah so whatever we give them as
a suggestion I guess but um in current
statute the the the Department of
Business and economic Affairs is already
listed as having this responsibility
so um they're already not doing
something they're supposed to be doing
this just makes it a little more clear
follow
up yes follow up so it it appears that
you want to um resuscitate this Statute
in order to address a gap that you feel
exists in the state being able to speak
intelligently with the federal
government about whether we're going to
move forward with anything to do with
Advanced reactor technology here in the
state is that correct and we don't have
anywhere to start because there's no
point there's no point person yeah
there's no there's no grounding in
statute for that whole subject area you
know Loosely maybe under atomic energy
but but the specifically this Advanced
reactor devel so do you foresee the
state doe being being the point in terms
of that inter that conversation or that
interaction yes that's how it's written
okay thank
you I'm trying to figure out if this is
an early bill or not oh
yeah if it is it's going to go
to house finance it is an early bill
it's due out the 15th of February so
this will be going to house finance so
my next question for you then would be
how are you going to
justify the expenditures in this bill
before house
finance I'd like to hear uh the from the
business of economic uh Affairs how they
justify hiring a whole new person for
that position maybe we can clarify the
language to make it clear that they
don't need to hire a nuclear expert to
participate in a five-year study you
know once every five years
so okay good additional questions for
representative Amin seeing none well
next call on the department of energy
and uh Griffin Roberge to give us the
Department's take on this proposed
legislation I'm going to leave these in
the committee room I have to move on to
another appointment so I won't be able
to stay but thank you yes thank you
appreciate
that Mr
robers
uh thank you members of the committee uh
for the record Griffin Rober sty program
manager at the New Hampshire Department
of energy um the department is neutral
to this bill as introduced um as was
previously mentioned um the bill revises
a section of state statute that has been
in existence and has remained untouched
since
1955 um working its way around the room
now is a letter of testimony from the
Department with our observations on the
bill as has been mentioned um the bill
makes a number of changes but primarily
from the Department's perspective it uh
requires the department and several
other state agencies to uh conduct
continuing studies uh as to whether any
changes in State Statute or
administrative rule are needed for
nuclear activity taking place in the
state and those agencies have to publish
uh reports on their continuing studies
no later than December 1 to
25 um it also requires a Department's
commissioner or Design Within the
department to serve as an advisor to the
governor on nuclear energy and to serve
as a coordinator of nuclear development
activities um this involves a number of
different responsibilities such as
coordinating with the Department of
Business and of economic Affairs and
coordinate and uh collecting and I guess
gu um summarizing a lot of the
coordinating studies being put together
by the other state agencies and then
finally it requires the coordinator to
be fully informed of all activities
undertaken um by other state agencies on
nuclear energy matters it also makes
clear that no administrative rule
specifically applying to a nuclear
energy matter shall be adopted unless
and until it has been submitted to the
coordinator that would be placed in our
department um as far as the Bill's
impact on the department um the
department is also tasked with uh
completing continuing studies under that
section two of the bill on page two um
the department as well as the Public
Utilities Commission must particularly
study the transportation of special
nuclear materials and byproduct
materials by Common carriers or public
or private air carriers that are not
involved in interstate commerce and the
participation of Public Utilities
they're subject to the state's
jurisdiction in projects look looking to
the development of uh nuclear facilities
for industrial or commercial use um by
way of background um the establishment
of this position as has been mentioned
was a recommendation from the uh
commission to investigate the
implementation of Next Generation
nuclear reactor technology in New
Hampshire which was created by House
Bill 543 um two years ago the department
is unaware if the coordinator's duties
are currently being fulfilled by another
state agency but I think the prime
sponsor pre uh previously indicated he
had looked into that and nobody's
currently doing that um the department
could absorb the duties um of this bill
by creating a new position and
repurposing some existing federal funds
for this position however we do want to
note that the department would have to
reduce some programmatic activities that
it currently undertakes with those funds
to fund this position on a continuing
basis um and additionally for background
I did want to note that department does
not have any sizable regulatory role
over energy generation but the
legislature has in the past created new
positions to look at specific energy
generation resources um for example we
do have an office of offshore wind
industry development that was created um
in recent years and that is funded under
the state's renewable energy fund under
the renewable portfolio standard um with
that happy to take any questions that
folks might have thank you thank you
appreciate you being here and giving us
your perspective on this legislation I
have a quick question for you the way I
read the existing statute that the bill
modifies the only thing
that state departments or state agencies
are required to do is submit a report
occasionally about what legal statutory
changes might need to be made if
any so it's not asking anybody to study
the nuclear in industry it's just simply
saying are there any statutory or
regulatory barriers that exist within
your department that you could report on
isn't that essentially what's going on
here sure and thank you for the question
I am I currently work for one Department
I couldn't imagine working for multiple
ones so I cannot speak for uh the other
departments who are implicated in this
business B um I think it would be
helpful for the committee to look at in
its entirety um RSA 162b colon 3 which
is the section that's being amended by
section two on page two specifically if
you look at line 17 on page two you're
going to see a colon at the end of that
line that if it if if the bill had
continued it would list out the duties
that would be attached to each of the
different state agencies so for example
the Department of Health and Human
services to your point uh Mr chairman is
required to look at any potential uh
administrative rule or statutory changes
uh quote particularly as to hazards if
any to the public health and safety um
Department of Labor particularly any
hazardous working conditions as to
whether any uh as to the time and
character of proof of of claims of
injuries in the extent of compensation
allowable therefore
so the language is quite Broad in the in
the remainder of the statute so I I
can't explain where
um where different agencies might be
coming from in terms of what they're
asking for for administrative resources
to complete these continuing studies but
um you know the Pu and the department of
energy specifically have two things that
we look at that we would be tasked with
looking into and then we'd have that
coordinator position kind of wrap all of
this
together representative Harrington has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question um looking at
this and you say the law has been
changed since 1955 yet since then we've
built a nuclear plant in New Hampshire
and that's been running uh for quite
some time now uh I wouldn't even care to
guess how many other people have a
license from the NC to handle
radioactive material such as industrial
radiography uh uh who knows what um uh
so there's there ongoing nuclear
activities in the state and obviously it
they're being done without any oversight
from all this on this law because nobody
even knew it was around um so could this
be taken and just shrunk down to say
we're going to have a coordinator a
person in the department of energy will
be the coordinator contact person for
the State of New Hampshire on any all
nuclear issues and not assign things to
other departments which really have to
they'll do a study basically to show
they're doing nothing uh and they could
really shrink this down and get rid of
all this uh fiscal note stuff and yet
let people know like other states have
done that hey we're open for nuclear
power in New Hampshire and we hope you
come here but uh all this regulatory
stuff we don't have puc has got nothing
to do with it anymore anyways sure and
no I thank you for the question the
observations I would just note that to
the extent the committee wishes to
modify the remainder of the statute to
kind of consolidate the state agencies
who are involved in these studies I
would again as I referenced in my lay of
testimony there is an office office of
offshore wind development that's in our
office that's currently an existing
statute that may be a a good place to
maybe start as maybe a a place to May
build an
amendment represent Vice chair Thomas
has a question thank you Mr chair thank
you for taking my question uh really
quick um by re by re revitalizing the
statutes uh and if it still passes would
this have an effect on your uh on the
state's uh 10-year energy plan in terms
of what goes in
there uh thank you for the question so
this bill does not specifically address
the statute as it pertains to um the
state's 10-year uh State energy strategy
um however I imagine you know um to the
extent nuclear technology becomes more
in the mainstream or becomes more
developed in later years um I imagine
our strategy will likely have some
discussion on nuclear power for example
the recent one um has a short write up
of uh Seabrook and its uh usage in the
state follow up uh yes thank you uh I
guess what I I meant to ask was do you
see perhaps a need in this bill or
whatever it comes out as to um I don't
like to use the word mandate but to
require that the reports that this bill
um is is citing
uh would be would be used in the
development of your 10year energy plan
thank so it's not a it's not a mandate
now under State Statute if that is
something that the legislature wanted to
change it's certainly free to do so but
like I said we do we do make uh we do
make an effort in our strategy right now
to discuss nuclear power in the state of
New Hampshire in the
strategy representative Kaplan has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you Mr robar for coming in sure um you
say that the department of energy could
meet at Staffing these by repurposing
some federal funds yes and therefore you
might have to curtail some programmatic
activities that are already being
undertaken can you be more specific
about what those programmatic activities
might be have those decisions been made
or what what do you foresee happening
with that sure so ideally the federal
funds that we would use if this became
law um that we would likely repurpose
include uh State energy program dollars
uh that we receive from the US
Department of energy that is typically a
annual Federal grant that all states
receive that varies based on federal
Appropriations every year but typically
it's within the range of $450 to
$500,000 a year um that currently now is
used to pay for uh the person sitting
before you um as well as other
programmatic aspects such as um anou a
memorandum of understanding that we
currently have with the Department of
administrative services for
Energy Efficiency projects and state
owned facilities um we also use it to
run a one-time competitive grant program
every year called the seed grant program
it is um it's an acronym but um it is a
competitive grant program to public
schools for Energy Efficiency projects
and that has been ongoing since I think
2018 okay seeing no more questions I'd
like to thank you for being here this
morning Mr Roberge and with that I'm
going to close the public hearing on
House Bill
and in four minutes I will start a new
public hearing so if you need to take a
bio break please do so
now
okay ladies and Gentlemen please take
your seats so that we can move on
here we
have another uh piece of legislation I'd
like to open a public hearing on House
Bill 1508 requiring fiber optic op IC
Communication service providers to
prioritize service restoration for
Public Safety and public health
organizations and I'd like to call on
the Bill's Prime sponsor representative
mamia to introduce this legislation good
morning and
welcome please turn on your mic thank
you good morning Mr chairman and
honorable members of the committee I am
representative Lind
mamea excuse
me and I represent the town uh Grafton
district one uh which is North
Country um I brought this bill
forward to uh House Bill
1508 looks at
prioritizing when there is a disruption
in services
um of prioritizing public health and
safety
organizations this bill came about
because of an incident that
happened excuse me that happened in
Littleton and the chief of police is
here to describe this tell you what
happened and also to answer any
questions regarding that
incident um the bill I know it has some
issues as far as the broadness of its
language and stuff like that but where
the North Country depends a lot on fiber
optics um I thought this was a timely
bill um as I said chief of police uh
Paul Smith will be uh presenting and um
he will answer any questions I hope you
will consider maybe putting this into an
interim study to debate the uh Merit of
the Bill thank
you okay thank you I think we want to
hear from Mr Smith so um seeing no
questions of Representative mameo thank
you for being here and introducing the
bill and Mr Smith
please give us your perspective on this
proposed legislative
change and welcome to st& thank you for
making the long drive down here
thank you Mr chairman and uh thank you
the committee to uh allow me to just
give you a little perspective uh as to
kind of an uphill battle that we add we
have to address um uh certainly in the
North country but I I would say that um
a lot of Public Safety organizations uh
um don't want to have to deal with the
the circumstances that I dealt with
concerning um f for Optics um as
technology advanced um things there was
there is a lot more um emphasis on fiber
optics and how uh we utilize it in
public safety for example uh I use our
fiber optics um for our voice over IP
telephone
Communications uh we definitely use um
uh the internet fiber optics um for
obtaining warrants search warrants some
of those have to be emergency warrants
uh we use it for um all of our evidence
written evidence photographic evidence
it's all uploaded into a cloud our
records management is in a cloud um and
also
um our security our cameras our body
cameras all the things that we do we
rely on fiber optics to have these
things uploaded and stored and to have
access to it so
on May 12th uh we were notified by uh
secured Network Services that and this
is I'm sorry
2023 um that they were going to change
their site that they were they were they
had to locate they're going to relocate
and um they advised us that we had to
contact our fiber optic uh provider um
to move their equipment to the new
location so there'd be a smooth
transition uh this wouldn't be taking
place until
July so we we believe we gave him ample
notification we did notify him on May
15th we called them uh regarding this
matter and they were and uh we were
instructed to send a copy of the letter
of my request to their C customer
service um Department which we did the
email was sent and received uh on the
19th of July uh scared Network Services
contacted us to follow up on the status
of the equipment that needed to be
changed and uh for the move and because
had not heard um or seen anybody from
our uh fiber optics provider and they
were scheduled to be um out at their new
location on July 31st uh on July
26 and by the way at that point uh our
administrative Department contacted the
um uh the fiber optics uh provider um
and we were asking about the initial
email uh
and requesting service relocation to the
different email address obviously the
the new address that the secur Network
Services had um and it was determined
that our initial email was sent to
incorrect person not our fault it was
within the fiber optics company uh and
uh it was assigned to the wrong account
so it was an administrative error on
their behalf we said fine however you
need to move your equipment by the 31st
of July because
we we need our fiber optics to operate
efficient efficiently for Public Safety
um on the 26 we received another email
from the fiber optic optic company
requesting us to sign a document to
initiate this project so we did um
unfortunately that's how things happen
in U in the the commercial world right
and you know you get a sign and you have
to commit to spending money for these
resources again July 31st was our drop
dead date where we lose our fiber
connection I in uh like I instructed
earlier or informed you earlier we have
a lot of resources specifically our
telephone Communications that depend on
the fiber optics um we received an
introductory email on the 31st from the
uh project manager from the fiber optic
company stating that they would move
their equipment on the day that it was
already supposed to be moved uh on the
30 on the 1st of August we lost our
internet connection uh and uh we began
uh operating off of our redundant system
which is Wireless uh it just does not
have the capacity of all the things that
we certainly need video and audio
capabilities to upload and download um
as a result we lost numerous phone calls
um into our administrative and into the
police department
um also received an email from the
project manager stating there wasn't
enough capacity utilizing the current
equipment at their new location um so
um
they uh attached was a firm order of
commitment for us to review so basically
they didn't they didn't have the
capacity and Personnel uh
so um the fiber optics um people
scheduled a date which was 911
2023 um to basically initiate their
project so they were going to made us
make us wait from August 1st until
September 11th to finalize the project
for our fiber optics
Communications um on the second we spoke
to the project manager and explained our
situation directly uh and asked them to
expedite the movement of their equipment
um on the 8th I received an email from
the project manager advising there would
be they would be Expediting so now um it
took them 6 days to send us an email to
say that they would expedite the project
and then finally on the 9th um uh we
were able to we received communication
that somebody would be at um our
location in Littleton and um the fiber
was restored on the 9th of uh
August
so the impact of this particular
incident I think is pretty broad meaning
I made numerous phone calls specifically
to the um pu and I said hey you know is
there any way that you guys can step in
I assume that you regulate fiber and
help with this particular situation
because so many public safety and
Hospital uh entities rely on fiber
optics these days to communicate and to
provide Public Health health and Public
Safety uh the answer was no and I was
astonished by that because pu does
regulate many things but fiber is not
one of them I do know that the federal
government has its U grip on uh fiber
optics as well however as you know
they're very slow to respond so uh I
contacted my uh representative uh and
asked what can we do to at least
prioritize um the response with fiber
optics
uh in situations such as ours with um
Public Safety and public health um not
every Police Department not every Fire
Department Public Works Department and
maybe even some small hospitals uh
operate with redundancy they don't have
that
ability and the other options were that
the board of Selectmen uh just like with
cable can have a contract with your
cable company and and say this is the
way way we want things within our
community uh I think the citizens would
be put at a disadvantage if you if you
basically say hey you know what you guys
didn't respond properly so we're going
to restrict your fiber optics in our
community I don't think that's the best
option and I also think that that's a
slow response what we need is a uh
within the Pu which is already
established entity the ability to have a
response to a failure with fiber optics
companies within the state of New
Hampshire
thank
you well thank you chief for being here
and outlining the situation that
happened with you folks up there in
Littleton I do have a quick question for
you this bill talks specifically about
fiber optic
cables but aren't you basically talking
about broadband support no I I used to
think that too but broadband and fiber
are a little bit different fiber is a
lot faster so as our technology
increases we have more Demand on um how
much information and how much video that
for example we're downloading on our
body cameras fiber is is the best option
to get that information into the cloud
as quickly as possible or voice over IP
just that uh but Broadband is is a is a
little bit different than
fiber so
the fiber oit cable is the connection
that gets you
to your internet
connection
yes so it's the internet connection that
seems to be the problem here not the
fiber optic
cable the fiber optic company was
responsible for the equipment that's a
good question thank you uh for the
equipment that would relay the
information that was being on their
fiber optic lines to our internet
company okay uh we have quite a few
people who want to have and I'm not an
IT expert by the way so you may ask me
questions I can't we do have a couple of
other people who are going to testify so
we'll we'll be able to ask some
technical questions but uh Vice chair
Thomas would like to ask you a question
first thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question really quick so my
understanding is that in your efforts to
have those resolved
there you found there there was no state
agency or regulatory agency out there
that you could go to you were
effectively dealing strictly with the
fiber optic company per se you are
absolutely correct and that there was no
you had no contract that
established any type of priority service
then I mean the contract didn't say
anything about special services like
that no
sir
okay
representative Harrington has a question
uh thank you uh and thank you for taking
my question um I I understand you're not
an expert on this but you did make a
statement I'm just trying to figure out
if you was any research was done you did
the found out that the Pu was not does
not have authority and in fact unless
something's changed the FCC has
exclusive authority to regulate uh
internet services and the state cannot
do it uh did you did something change
since I was on the commission and maybe
uh is there a change in federal law
because my understanding is we couldn't
regulate it if we wanted to unless
something's changed uh that wasn't the
way it was explained to me that they had
exclusive Authority just that they did
do the federal government did regulate
uh although they were slow to respond um
I just believed that for circumstances
when it comes to Public Safety Public
Health uh obviously State Control State
ability to uh either and I don't have an
answer whether it's to fine or or I'm
not a proponent of excessive
regulation um even though I am in the
law enforcement side of the house we
know that we can't regulate our way out
of this but somebody or something within
the state of New Hampshire needs to hold
uh their feet to the
fire representative Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair um I'm not
trying to belittle I'm not trying to um
minimize I'm just trying to clarify
based on what you've testified is this a
customer service complaint with one
company or is this a problem throughout
New
Hampshire the the second question I
don't have enough data to to answer to
answer that appropriately the first
question
is um we have had similar issues with
other companies that we contract with uh
in the past specific dealing with either
internet communications uh or
telephone thank
you additional questions representative
McGee thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question Chief um the
language of the bill just basically says
that the provider of communication
Services as described in
RSA um through fiber optic cable shall
Upon A disruption of service prioritize
the restoration of communication and
internet access for critical
infrastructure of Public Safety and
public health organizations and I would
assume that might be a priority among
them already um informally if it's not
in statute so I'm wondering whether upon
disruption of service would actually
have taken care of the category of
disruption that you uh you were looking
for um upgrade of equipment I think
would would the language in this bill
actually have sufficed to cover your
circumstance
that's a good point um I
I I think that the system completely
failed in our
circumstance um but had it been a
priority I don't think that even if it
was based on the disruption on August
1st um that there was any priority
within that fiber optic company when
they wanted to do it on 9911 after
August 1st that to me didn't seem like
priority when I see their vehicle on our
Main Street every day so um maybe it not
would not have been fixed as much as I'm
a very impatient person as quickly as I
felt appropriate for a public safety or
public health um I don't think they
would have given us a a date of 911
maybe if they had something in in uh
response for the following day that
would have been more
appropriate representative Ms has a
question thank you Mr chair and um thank
you chief for taking my question and
your service to your community um can
you share the name of the provider with
us the fiber optic capable
provider I
can sure it was it was first light
okay thank you representative rolds has
a question thank you Mr chairman thank
you chief for being here um my question
is kind of following up on um
representative M's question you know I'm
listened carefully to your um to the
story and I'm looking at the language of
the bill and I'm just wondering
would this
legislation had it been in
effect
um last year uh would it have solved the
problem or I'm guess I'm wondering why
the legislation it says
that the the provider of fiber optic
service shall prioritize Public Safety
over commercial and
residential okay and as they say like
would think that a company would do that
anyway so is there is there a part of
the story that you didn't tell that the
company um first light was was was
working on homes and businesses and and
had service to them but not to the
Public Safety facility I can't testify
for for First Light except that I know
they had equipment in our region that
could have addressed it
immediately
um
so I don't believe I can answer your
question accurately unless we were to
have testimony from first FL okay thank
you additional questions for the
chief Vice chair Thomas has one thank
you uh m Mr chair thank you for taking
my question really quick because we've
had
a a bill kind of like this with an
unregulated agency before in the past I
I have to ask the question did you by
chance contact the Attorney General file
a
complaint I find out if there's other
complaints I did
not just a consideration thank
you additional
questions seeing none I want to thank
you chief for the uh for coming down
here taking the long drive to get here
and give us uh your perspective on this
legislation next up we're going to hear
from Griffin Roberge of the Department
of energy about this proposed
legislation
thank you uh Mr thank you Mr okay thank
you Mr chairman um thank you Mr chairman
uh for the record Griffin Rober State
energy program manager at the uh New
Hampshire Department of energy um
registering respectful opposition to
this bill as introduced working its way
around the room right now is a letter of
testimony from the Department um as has
been discussed the bill uh requires
Communications Services providers um
that provide service through fiber optic
cables to prioritize the restoration of
service uh for Public Safety and public
health organizations over commercial and
residential customers um Again by way of
background the state of New Hampshire
has either largely deregulated
Communication Service Pro service
providers or this area is overseen by uh
Federal Regulation um the state's
limited roles in this realm are really
focused on consumer fairs and saf safety
issues such as Crossing licenses across
a state land or down poles and wires and
roadways um that might impact Public
Safety or working between uh a customer
and their utility provider to resolve an
ongoing uh concern um Department wanted
to note several observations uh for the
committee's uh consideration um there
are ambiguous terms um uh terminology in
the bill such as public safety and
Public Health Organization on line six
while I think we all kind of know what
Public Safety and public health
organizations are I think other parties
could reasonably argue that they are
themselves Public Safety and public
health
organizations um one could make the
again one could make the argument that
they should be prioritized for
restoration um if they provide a direct
or indirect Public Service um another
note is again this puts the state in a
role of re-regulating unregulated
entities um again as I previously noted
this area has either been deregulated by
the state or taken over uh by Federal
Regulation um to promote customer choice
and competition um the passage of this
bill in its current form would
reintroduce the state into a type of
regulatory role over these entities um
to ensure that certain customers have
their service restored uh faster than
others do um I did also want to note
that based on the previous testimony and
I'm going to be fully transparent I'm
not fully aware of specifically all the
ins and outs of this specific uh
consumer case but the department does um
have a consumer services division that
regularly helps consumers interacting
with their utility or their service
provider um such examples include
assistant customers if issues arise when
establishing new utility or provider
service or acting as a mediator to
resolve disputes between customers and
their utility or their provider uh folks
are always willing to contact our
consumer services division as many
around the state do every day um and we
are more than willing to try to act in
that mediat position for any
municipality um that might have
difficulty um resolving an ongoing issue
um and with that uh happy to conclude my
testimony and take any questions that
folks might have thank you very much
questions from the committee
representative Kaplan has one thank you
Mr chair and thank you Mr Rober
uh I'm just wondering if I get your
opinion on this would this bill be
better uh placed in the Commerce
Committee would this be a uh a question
of uh Comm you know you don't have to
answer that that that that question is
probably not relevant to our proceeding
here okay representative Ms thank you Mr
chair and uh thank you Mr robers
um I'm not sure you can help me with
this but um so a company like like for
first fiber first light fiber do they do
they run their own
cables for that for specifically for
their fiber optic Communications or are
they sharing them with other
companies okay sorry I didn't know if
you were going to keep going that sorry
uh thank you for the question so um I am
again not familiar with the specifics of
this circumstance um but do want to note
that it you know it is my understanding
that first light with haveit own
infrastructure on utility polls that run
through S Litteton and then off of there
they Branch to different customers to
provide service um you know and I I also
do want to take the opportunity to also
note that you know we at the department
became aware of this specific
circumstance after it had occurred and
after it had fully resolved itself um
and I understand the concern from those
in Littleton about the the speed at
which um service was restored and that
type of thing thing um obviously again I
can't speak to the particulars of
um of the interactions amongst all the
parties but you know based on our
perspective is that this wasn't some
type of weather event or severe weather
event where you know lilton went without
service for a significant span of time
due to a natural event you know this
seems more like a customer service
related um issue um you know I would
just note that in the future if such
issues do arise more than will to
contact the department of energy and our
consumer services division as I
mentioned people do that on a regular
basis Vice chair Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chair thanks again for
taking my question so um I completely
understand about the the concern about
regulating and unregulated uh agency I
also concern about being a private
organization as well but uh is there
anything
in statute or regulations or rules or
whatever when a company comes to do
business here in the state that would
when they set a business here that they
that there would be some type of um
statement saying that on critical or
Safety
Services uh must be considered uh in
terms of ensuring that
services available under any any
circumstance sure and something like
that sure thank for the question so
obviously as private companies you know
they solicit customers as any normal
business does um but it's my
understanding that a lot of these um
companies like first light maybe Comcast
others you know they realize the
importance of prioritizing the
restoration of critical infrastructure
such as police departments Town Halls
water sewer utilities Etc so I believe
that they have policies in place and
work specifically with those th with
those towns those entities um to ensure
that they have maybe Priority Access to
the company to reach out if there are
concerns reach out um if there are any
major questions again obviously I
realize I cannot speak to the
particulars of this uh first light
instance but um yes I would say that
when companies do arrive in the state
I'm sure that they work with their with
their customers to identify ways that
they can contact them if needs arise
representative Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chair um this is regarding
point one
on your on your written testimony where
you say that there's ambiguous terms are
you telling us that the department of
education does Department of energy
sorry does not have a definition for
disruption of service or that the state
of New Hampshire does not have a
definition for Public Safety and public
health organizations sure and thank you
for the question so I'm sure that there
are but again in this specific bill that
is not specifically reference it doesn't
reference any other area of Statute or
anything like that as to what Public
Safety or public public health
organizations or what uh disruption of
service is again you know and I do want
to take the opportunity to note um the
prime sponsor's willingness to speak
with the Department about this bill um
representative mamila did reach out to
us asking questions about how best to
format the bill obviously we're at
different ends of the bill but um we
were honest candid with each other about
where we were coming from on on these
respective issues and we did highlight
in a um I did highlight in a
conversation with the prime sponsor last
week that you know we would be coming in
to identify that this was an area of
concern that we had in the bill um to
answer your immediate question are there
areas um in State Statute where Public
Safety or public health organizations
might be defined I would say there may
be I'm not a lawyer I don't know off the
top of my head followup follow up if if
if there are cases or if there may be
cases as you suspect is it fair to say
that this is um that that this bill does
not def Define them I mean if it's
already established in previous law it
doesn't need to be defined redefined
yeah I thank you for the question so yes
and you know the other thing I do want
to note is you
know I think in our read of the bill
that this was The Way It Was Written is
that it was focused on maybe weather
events that cause massive disruptions of
service but we re but I think we
recognize based on the specifics of this
case that introducing this level of
State oversight on a
relatively on a ver on a constit on an
isolated consumer issue that occurred
might be a heavy-handed approach to take
um again in conversations with our
consumer services division issues like
this do happen relatively
infrequently um you know maybe one or
two cases occurring maybe a year so
again if instances like that do occur we
encourage folks to certainly reach out
to our department and we're more than
willing to help try to mediate that I
realize it's a long answer and it's all
the way around but just wanted to make
the point thank
you okay seeing no more questions I want
to thank you for testifying thank you
and call our last speaker on this bill
and that's Teresa
Rosenberger representing the New
Hampshire telephone Association and
Consolidated
Communications good morning Miss
Rosenberger nice to see you again
welcome back to sdn good morning thank
you Mr chairman and nice to see all of
you on a typical New Hampshire day what
can we say uh I come before you today
representing the New Hampshire telephone
Association which is dun Barton
telephone Granite State uh TDS and
Breton woods and I also represent
Consolidated Communications and we
respectfully oppose this bill and we are
not opposing by any means that Public
Safety and public health is not number
one but we already have protocols we've
had them for decades we are the old Mell
landline companies that were highly
regulated way back when and so we've had
protocols in fact in Consolidated case
they've had protocols since over over a
century um so we don't think this is
necessary and I would agree with the
Department of energy that this does look
like more customer service than weather
Etc or outages Etc um we also all our
companies have a very good working
relationship with the Public Utilities
Commission and doe and I will say in my
experience and and as well as the
companies over the years if there's an
issue particularly a customer service
issue and the Pu or the consumer
Advocate it's called we usually get a
telephone call you know hey just want to
let you know this is going on and we've
gotten this complaint so there is a good
communication and good working working
relationship there um we also sit on the
um 911 Commission
so clearly coordination cooperation with
the Department of Safety so I would say
to I'm very sorry to have to oppose what
sounds like we're opposing Public Safety
but we're not because we really do now
and um this is not as you've heard this
is not a customer of ours and I'm sorry
it happened I feel badly for for
Littleton I can't imagine what a
horrible situation but I'd be happy to
take any any questions on it thank you
Vice chair Thomas has a question thank
you Mr chair thanks for taking my
question so um I'll ask this not in a
negative way but it sounds like you were
were saying that perhaps uh uh the
customer contacted the wrong people with
with their issue because they they
weren't able to get a resolved very
quickly at all I'm not sure who they
contacted all I know is from my
experience if and and and I've asked the
companies now because I did run fearo at
one point and I did get calls from the
Pu quite a bit oh by the way there's a
problem in West Morland or there's a
problem here
[Music]
um we certainly have communication
meaning the landline companies with the
the um consumer Folks at the Pu you
would hope they would call if there was
an issue I don't know what happened in
this case I I don't know I don't know
who the police chief called I don't know
I don't know what the communication was
I assume it was directly with the
company follow up I'm not sure I
answered that the way you wanted or the
way you asked you you did answer it U uh
because you don't know but no I don't U
but uh so in the future what would you
what would you recommend uh on something
like as critical as a say the the police
or even health and safety in the future
could you recommend anything in here
that could be stated uh or at least made
known about who to call to get immediate
relief I guess besides going to the AG I
guess
I would certainly say I wouldn't put it
in statute and I know for my companies
they work well with the municipalities
and there usually is a contact person
with particularly because of police and
fire there's a specific contact person
so I don't think this needs to be
legislated if you do anything maybe
interim study it but because the process
seems to be working at least on the
landline side and it sounds like from I
saw uh Miss Weston's testimony for Nea
it certainly seems like is working on
the cable side so um I think better
communication of better Point persons
with whoever the contractor is the
provider would be my
suggestion
okay representative Ms has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question and nice to see you
again um necta is that the organization
that that a company like f like first
light would be part of do they are they
the the internet provider no I think and
I think Miss Weston is behind me so she
can clarify if I'm not correct necta is
the cable company so it would be comf
Charter Charter
Spectrum and Spectrum I think it's
Comcast Charter and Spectrum okay so I
don't know who first
light who they're associated with but um
but I do know the cable companies and
the AL Mell companies all have processes
in place that have been working well as
far as this is concerned and there the
other thing I did not
say it is very clear that we have to
wait for electric so if there's a
disruption of service for example a
weather event electric has has first
they have to go up first we we can't go
up because obviously it's really
dangerous if you've got electrical wires
that are that are alive and Etc so
whenever there's a disaster or
disruption of service they're first and
then we go
next representative PL has a
question thank you chair and thank you
for taking my question um I didn't quite
hear but could you offer some
information you might know on the
providers you represent do they now
prioritize between residential
commercial and public service for
disruption of Serv of yeah Public Safety
for disruption of service is that
already being done yes that has been
done for decades with my clients and it
is police fire and then health so it's
police fire hospitals any that goes in
that health emergency but police and
fire are at the top of the the top of
the list public health and Public Safety
um are absolutely top of the list and
they always have been I don't know this
for a fact but I would guess way back
when when there was all the regulation
and these companies started that was a
priority and I certainly know when when
I ran fear point there was absolutely no
question what was number one and even
though you might have mad customers
calling up saying why aren't you
restoring my service well you got to get
police and fire number one in the
hospitals that I mean
it's it's what we value frankly
representative Harrington has a question
yeah thank you and thank you for taking
my question um just with regard to your
company um one of the biggest complaints
I get on anything is not able to contact
people so if I were to pick up the phone
now and called one of your companies uh
what I get we value very much as a
customer your approximate wait time will
be three and a half years or will
somebody actually answer the phone well
you know that's what we're talking about
here I know I know I know I know I will
tell you when I call I get a person and
I end up getting service now I don't
have a special number but I do and I
will honestly tell you I haven't called
Breton Woods or Granite State recently
consol I'm conquered and Consolidated
it's my my carrier and I get I get
service I get an and I get people out
there and U and particularly when my
internet goes down I'm calling oh my God
I can't work cuz during Co I work work
from home um you know on a with a storm
you might you might have to hold a few
minutes but I certainly have gotten um
gotten people okay quick followup follow
up did the police on Fire have a uh like
a hotline number where they call with a
247 is person going to answer the phone
or do they put on or they call on the
same place that everybody else every
other customer calls it is my
understanding and it certainly was when
I was at FairPoint but it's my
understanding there's a special oh
there's a specific contact with police
and
fire I don't know whether it's I don't
know what the phone number is but but I
unfortunately think or I should say
fortunately think you and you and I are
not quite treated like like police on
fire which is
good the only thing standing between us
and lunch is representative McGee has a
question and that is not unusual okay um
so from listening to all this gone on I
I would like you to comment on this is a
company that's not associated with you
and you say you have protocols in place
where the police and fire would have
that priority so if it seems like there
wasn't that priority placed on the you
know the Advan notice nothing was done
it just
inside the company things weren't going
well would you recommend that that the
chief use um Littleton Town Council or
or Littleton Town officials to reach out
to the company because it seems like
it's an issue with the company that
needs to be straightened out in terms of
their priorities I would honestly think
if you got a call from the police chief
you would act I mean frankly if Town
Council fine and dandy but if the police
chief calls I would think you would go
all the way at the top and and I mean
it's surprising to me from a customer
service
perspective um that this happened and I
think it's really unfortunate but you
would sure think you go to the the top
and even if you had to leave a voicemail
you would think if somebody answered the
voicemail they go oh gosh it's the
Littleton Police
and you know we got to we got to do
this okay I guess okay yeah thank you I
appreciate thank you and if you would if
you would like I'll be happy to call all
my companies and see if they answer the
phone okay if you want to take the time
to do that feel free well I F all right
having no more pink cards I'm going to
close the public hearing on House Bill
1508 and we're going to adjourn now for
lunch and we will return at 1:00 to hear
house bills
1576 FN see you at
1:00
for
okay good afternoon everybody and
welcome back to the afternoon session of
st& for Monday the 29th we have three
public hearings that we're going to be
attending to this
afternoon the first one is on HB 1576 FN
relative to allowing Property Owners to
opt out of Public
Utilities we'll follow that with a
public hearing on hb600 FN relative to
participation in net energy
metering and then we'll close out the
day with a hearing on hb1 1644 FN
requiring the department of energy to
initiate an investigation of the
benefits and key considerations
regarding support for clean or noncarbon
emitting power
generation so let's first open a public
hearing on hb7 1576 FN relative to
allowing Property Owners to opt out of
Public Utilities and I'll ask the prime
sponsor representative Eric Alan to
introduce this proposed legislation to
the committee thank you representative
for being here good to see you good to
see you too Mr chairman thank you all so
much for coming back hopefully refreshed
from lunch and ready to talk about some
great topics here for the record my name
is Erica Lon and I'm a state
representative from Derry um before I
moved to Derry I actually was looking
only at homes that had um had Public
Water and Sewer because the idea of a
septic system scared me now that I've
been on a well in a septic system for
over 20 years I love it um so the reason
that I filed this bill is because we
have more and more areas where there are
sewer sewer and water projects that are
passing existing properties in order to
go to new developments or to go to
failed sites either for Wells or for
septic systems um there does not seem to
be consistency on how those passing
homeowners and property owners are
treated um to whether they're able to
opt out or if they're forced to opt in
or if a neighborhood requires everybody
to participate in order to offer that
water and
sewer unless you have a failed well or a
failed septic system um I believe that a
property owner should be able to opt out
of that public water and sewer that are
coming by and continue to use a
functioning well and a functioning sewer
Sy septic system by doing that you more
have to be more aware of what goes down
your waist we're careful about what
toilet paper what wipes go down there
you're far more sensitive when you are
the one who is on the hook for fixing
what happens with your septic system and
it it also leads to a lot more people
paying more attention to the actual
quality of the water that the family is
drinking because it is your well water I
think it keeps you closer to Nature it
keeps you closer to your environment and
makes you a better Steward of what is
around you I recognize that some people
don't take on those responsibilities but
unfortunately that's life there are some
people who are less responsible and we
do have the ability to deal with failed
SE systems and there are already those
processes in place um we actually have
some of the septic systems in Dairy
because there were failed septic systems
around Beaver Lake and in that situation
I would not say that somebody should be
able to opt out um because at that point
you have an environmental hazard the
question becomes should I have to tie in
just because it passes my property
I believe that that default should be no
it should be voluntary and that's why I
filed this bill I did draft it largely
to all public utilities because I had
heard of people who were told that they
were not able to be fully off-grid for
electrical reasons um apparently that's
entirely fine and people are allowed to
not connect into the grid since that's
not a problem I don't have concern over
that and I'd be happy to narrow the
scope of this to only Water and Sewer um
but my intention is just to allow people
to continue to be close to their land to
continue to manage that water that comes
in and goes out be a good Steward and
not need to tie in to town Water and
Sewer if they would rather continue to
have that responsibility on their own
and with that I'd be happy to take any
questions thank you good introduction to
the bill and I'm sure we do have some
questions representative McGee would
like to start thank you Mr chairman and
thank you representative Lan for taking
my question so the question that I had
in reading the bit Bill about um giving
the option for connection or capping
when a project is coming through is
whether you discussed this with any um
people Town people who are responsible
for water and store because um my
question would be around um whether
there's a difference between rural areas
like mine where I have my own well and
septic like you were describing it's
very common in certain areas but in
other areas
it isn't and the the water system or the
sewage system is definitely part of the
infrastructure that is maintained on the
whole for the benefit of the many and it
would maybe be problematic if people
were opting out so did you do any
Research into how it would actually work
uh well thank you for the question I'm
going to take that sort of as a two-part
question one about the way of connecting
and the other about the very small uh
more densely packed Lots um looking at
all the regulations around septic
systems you need to have a certain
setback and you need to have a certain
radius in order to have your septic
system be one that can be certified and
approved um I believe in the language of
this bill and in my intention for this
bill if you're not able to have an
allowed permitted septic system you
wouldn't have that option of opting out
so by saying that by by leaving it to
those existing rules and statutes about
what is an acceptable septic system I
believe that would address the issues
around any any close any very small
properties that would not support um
their own septic system so um I I don't
believe that there would be challenges
with that but that's but if there's any
sort of um unique situations that' be
interesting to hear about um the second
is um the way that we attach to our
properties I believe goes all the way up
to the exterior of the home here I do
have to say that some of my Approach was
slightly colored by dealing with a
massive failure of water and sewer at a
family member's house in another
location where they do actually just
have a box that they come to and it's
the city responsibility to that box and
it's the homeowner beyond that and
within that idea where it's only Built
out to a certain distance and that the
homeowner's responsibility to continue
that path to the house my thought was
that that would be a lower cost process
I did see the testimony from um that was
emailed from um the depart Department of
Environmental Services and uh the fact
that you can actually tap into it in the
future I think is wonderful and great
and would probably remove the need to
have one of those hookup sections unless
you had something like a brand new road
that was being paved and you wouldn't be
able to access it I I simply want to
make sure that one homeowner's Choice
isn't going to FLIR close on the choice
for anybody who purchases that property
in the future which is why I wanted to
make sure that you weren't creating a
situation where the cost to tapen in the
future could be exorbitant um either
because of the potential that not the
people involved now but I try and
legislate for the people who may someday
in it be in a position I want to make
sure that if somebody wanted to be
punitive about that um they wouldn't be
able to and that's why there was a
section about the reasonableness of the
fees I don't expect that anybody who's
in the Departments today would be doing
that but I'd rather legislate for the
possibilities as opposed to the good
people who are here today I just see
that as responsible legislating so it
was my attemption to my attempt to meet
the needs between the two but if there's
other solutions to that i' I'd love to
hear them I'd be very open to
them okay representative Corman had a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question so uh in
response to representative McGee you
said that uh if a homeowner has a
property that is not cleared for a
septic then uh they may opt out can you
point me to where it says that in the
bill please um it's that they would not
be able to opt out so when I ni yeah I'm
sorry they would not be able to opt up
yes it looks that that was left out of
the draft and I apologize for that I had
language that I had sent over to OS for
that and I'd be very happy to bring that
back in for you I apologize for missing
that oversight in the drafting process
thank
you
representative Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chair um so we're a little
different in my neighborhood we have
four houses that have private Wells that
are so contaminated with past that we're
waiting we're desperately waiting to be
connected up to public water
um right now those four houses we live
on bottled water for everything that we
drink or cook you know it's it's pretty
bad so my question is if somebody is
choosing to opt out of let's say public
water coming down their street is there
some kind of a mechanism to make sure
that the water that they're keeping
their private well is is healthy and
uncontaminated or does that have nothing
to do with us uh well thank you for that
question um as far as that goes it's a
responsibility of the homeowner to know
the quality of their water and when
there's already an existing
well-published publicized issue such as
what you're facing in your community um
it'd be quite shocking for somebody not
to do that however there are mitigation
Pro uh processes I know that in our
house we have pretty good water um but
we still do a good amount of treatment
between a water softener a whole house
filter and then R for um the more for
any of our drinking water obviously not
for the showers because that would cause
extra waste because of all the waste
water that does come from that Reverse
Osmosis System uh but there may be
somebody who's already mitigated that of
the incoming water from their well and
they may have other reasons why they
prefer to do that um so forcing somebody
to do that when they may have already
mitigated the problem I don't think
would be appropriate however an
information campaign if it is coming
because of a contamination issue would
be very important and quite frankly I'd
probably be going by with some cookie
some brownies baked with bottled water
and making sure all my neighbors knew
about the risk uh because it is a real
risk and I appreciate that and actually
and sorry if I go go back to rep
corman's um question it actually says
that any customer of a public water util
on lines um 10 11 12 uh through 13 that
actually references the statutes um
about the requirements for the septic
system so that's a reference to the rsas
that cover the septic
systems so if you're not able to meet
the requirements or meet a waiver that's
been accepted by Dees then you would not
be able to terminate that
connection representative Harrington has
a question thank you and thank you for
taking my question I I noticed you've uh
specifically talk about public utilities
or Municipal corporation uh would this
apply to private water systems for
example someone puts in a condominium
development and they may have their own
private water system or or same thing
with surage for that matter so it's not
a public utility because it's owned by
the uh members of the U you know
Cooperative whatever whatever that
happened to be called it's also been
done in housing developments where
someone will put in uh you know 10 or 12
houses someplace and they'll have a
central well for all of them because
it's cheaper than putting in 12 Wells uh
so would that be affected by this or
would this be only Public Utilities or
Municipal owned uh corporations well um
thank you for that question that's an
area that I hadn't looked at quite as
closely in a condominium situation or
something else where you've been able to
change the zoning requirements so you
can have people more densely packed in
one section of the property and leave
others open space um there are some ways
that those water and septic systems
because sometimes there are larger
septic systems the way that they're
handled are actually pull from that
large larger area of land underneath the
property in order to cover the space
needed for it sorry it's been a while
since I looked at this I was an
architecture minor I want to develop
stuff I I love all of this so excuse me
if I get a little bit on the surface of
these so when you when you get to some
of those approvals for those um
congregate Wells and congregate septics
some of those already sort of block off
a Zone about what would be acceptable
for any other well um I I would think
that in a private situation it may make
sense to do that within the agreements
of your private um private organization
um and that's not one that I had looked
too closely into
followup follow up yeah what I'm trying
to get at is let's just say there was a
private agreement and then you're living
there and then you decide you want to
put in your own well or whatever so you
say I want to disconnect would this law
allow you to do that and would this say
this doesn't apply because you're not a
public utility or Municipal owned
Corporation um I'd be happy if you
wanted to add that amendment to it okay
I know that I don't join I don't move
live anywhere that has those agreements
because my mother's um condo in
California refused to get earthquake
insurance and those consequences follow
everybody
else um before we get to some other
questions and there are other questions
I just need a quick clarification if you
could please this bill modifies RSA
62 which is the limited electrical
producer
users
Act and the focus of that act is mostly
on electric
electricity uh
issues the legislation that governs
sewers is RSA 49- I do you think this
legislation might more properly reside
under uh 149 I as opposed to
362 um yes I think that probably would
be a much better fit um and I apologize
I was reaching beyond my core areas
where I can St spout the rsas and thank
you for catching that um I think it
would belong much better in this than
for that
clarification okay next up is
representative muns thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question um
if if someone opts out of um service
from any utility water sewer or electric
does there need to be some kind of hold
harmless provision that protects the
utility from any claims that that that
individual might make in the invent of
an emergency where they all of a sudden
want to have be connected to the grid
you know the next
day well um thank you for that question
I I would believe that any contract that
you have for somebody opting out should
have that hold harmless um so if that's
something that you wanted to add to the
bill I would absolutely appreciate that
this does say that in the future
somebody who wants to connect it
basically lays out that there already
would be a proscribed process for that
and I was envisioning more somebody who
either because they had gotten very old
and didn't want to maintain it maybe
they had somebody who had family issues
where they didn't or they sold it to
somebody who was really excited about
not having to deal with a septic system
and that future owner wanted to connect
but uh because it does allow for a
already prescribed procedure for
somebody to return to that system or
join the system in the first time I
would expect that that would be included
in that process so that nobody nobody
can have any an expectation of snapping
their fingers and having Serv Services
because that's just not
reality representative Corman has a
question thank you again and thank you
again uh I'd like to ask about par uh
paragraph 4 uh on page two lines 6
through
13 and I'm a little unclear on exactly
uh how this would apply so I'm imagining
there's a street and several homeowners
decide to opt out and the utility says
no we're going to connect to you and
therefore this um this fine would apply
would it apply just once or would it
apply to each individual
homeowner um so thank you for the
question the way that I had intended it
um it says to the property owner but if
there was a class action that that may
make sense as well the reason why when I
was discussing it there was a cap on it
would just be to make sure that you
wouldn't have a bunch of different
people coming in and essentially
bankrupting it because um they were
going through the process because if
there was a situation where somebody was
told that in order to connect in you
would need to tear up a new roaded um it
would then need to connect in and then
you would need to pay for a
reconstruction of that road bed in order
to do that that would be prohibitive and
that's why there's an intention to allow
to have have a spur in that sort of
situation that the homeowner could um
could be charged for that spur to then
connect to in the future because you
need to be able to account for the
situation where it's a road where it's
not a problem tapping it in or if it's a
larger Road where you actually would
have infrastructure problems with
tapping in in the future and to be able
to allow those processes for them to set
around a project what the if there's any
opt out cost because there is a value to
a future homeowner being able to tap
into that into that system and I
understand the idea of charging a
certain amount because it is CH passing
in front of you and so that you don't
have to pay to fix that roaded issue if
you're tapping in that's why having an
ability to have a Spur like they do in
other areas that you would Connect into
that is past the improved edge of the
road is something that to me seemed like
a reasonable offering where then the
homeowner is responsible from that point
to the to the rest of the way to the
house I'm trying to find a way where
it's fair to people who are opting out
fair to those who are opting in in the
future and fair to those rate payers who
are still on there because if somebody's
going to preserve an option when it's
going down say the new Exit 4 a perhaps
there's a cost so that in the future you
can tie in but it also shouldn't be that
ongoing obligation and forcing you to
leave a A system that you appreciate and
that you enjoy followup yeah thank you
I'm still just trying to wrap my head
around um the the fine issue here
so let's imagine that there are two
different locations that the same
utility is serving and that there are
multiple homeowners on at both those
locations and that the utility is is
doing the wrong thing is this
250,000 just that's a
lifetime uh cap for the utility or is it
250,000 per neighborhood per homeowner
that's what I'm trying to understanding
get clarity on because I find that this
language doesn't tell me well I mean
thank you for that question
my my expectation as thought is that
they would be following the statutes and
by having an enforcement provision that
is simply there in order to make sure
that good people continue to make good
decisions I'd frankly have a much larger
concern if we had um if we had the
systems routinely making decisions that
were in violation of statutes and I
think that would be an indication of a
far larger problem quite frankly so I
recognize your concern but I don't think
that they would be acting in such a
reckless way so I don't think that it
actually would be a would be a problem
in in in actual
practice representative McGee has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
again okay so I'm on section three of
the bill and uh Parts A and B uh were of
interest to me so a says that all new
residential electric gas water or sewer
projects must detail how the core
project cost and individual property
connection costs are calculated
and provide for payment in full and
delayed payment including the mechanism
to determine the cost for property
owners to connect in later years and um
then it talks about how people can
structure their payments um from
Property Owners uh and allow different
methods for payment but when I think
about the reality of how developments
are going up for example um in my area
many times uh a developer will be
proposing a development plan of 50
houses 30 houses um and so their costs
may be the same for all the houses in
their development but they're uh
projected based on them knowing that
they're going to be running gas or
whatever system for heating for all of
them water sewer obviously they have to
provide for it to be habitable um so I
don't understand how this will work if
it's uh a mandate that all new
residential electric gas water and sewer
projects now have to have this opt out
if you want to because many times when
they're building them they have to spec
for all of those systems and they don't
know who's going to buy them so I don't
I don't understand how it would work in
practice well thank you for the question
who's the owner of the development while
these services are provided well it's
new construction so it would be the
developer who's the owner correct y so
the developer would would make that
choice to connect most likely make that
choice to connect everybody to that
system and it would take further action
for somebody to be able to get an
approved septic design and be able to
get an approved well when they're
already tied in in a development that
already provides it so the likelihood
that somebody who would want to move to
a new development and then pay the cost
of a septic system and a well when
there's already water going to it is
very low um I I own property that could
potentially be developed into quite a
few homes um I'm trying to preserve that
forest and that land but I also have a
lot of neighbors that if I were to do
that and if everybody who was passed by
the septic and water was forced to
connect they would have a major change
in how they ran their homes and I want
to make sure that whether I'm that
developer or somebody else's those
people who are passed by the water and
SE and Sewer in on their way to go serve
that new development aren't forced to
join the system if they don't want to
and if they already have a good good
balance with nature in their home and in
their
property okay I further questions yeah I
just I don't know of any scenarios where
that where anyone who has a a septic and
well would be required to take a
different Source usually if you're
already selfcontained nobody's going to
force you change we're here to ask
questions any further
questions seeing none I want to thank
you for introducing this legislation to
us there actually was a bit of a
question in that there was a project
that required ired full optin in Dairy
in order for it to proceed and anybody
who who was against it still would have
been forced to participate in that sewer
SE system and water system so it would
have been a majority vote the majority
did not vote for that septic sewer and
water so it did not happen but it would
have happened regardless for those who
did not want to participate so thank
you okay seeing no further questions we
want to thank you representative for
introducing this proposed legislation
thank you and next we would like to hear
from the New Hampshire Department of
Environmental Services so I'd like to
invite Tracy
wood and also
umand
Brandon
Kernan kernin okay not a lot of space on
these pink cards to write names so sorry
if I got that wrong but apologize to you
no that Miss Wood it's great to see you
it's been a while since I've seen you
and it's nice to have you uh have you
back back thank you good to see
you so thank you for having us chairman
and members of the committee uh de has
submitted a letter of testimony I don't
know if it's made its way around um but
New Hampshire Dees opposes this bill um
I'll speak to the Sewer side my name is
Tracy wood and I'm the administrator of
the Wastewater engineering Bureau at D
and Brandon kernin who is the
administrator of the drinking water and
groundwater Bureau will speak
specifically to drinking water um so on
the sewer piece um we oppose it because
it conflicts with existing statutes so
the main statute RSA 1478 requires that
if you're going to occupy a building
that you need to have public or access
to public water and sewer or you can
have for sewer a private septic system
as well but you need to have proper
sewage and water facilities
that RSA also requires that if you're
within 100 feet of the sewer you as
you've heard today that you need to
connect to
that stepping back a little bit back to
the Clean Water Act 50 years ago when we
came when they built all the wastewater
treatment facilities in New Hampshire
and specifically to the RSA that you
cited which is 149 I um that's specific
to sewer use ordinances and so each
community that built a wastewater
treatment plant was required to also
have a sewer use ordinance which defines
on how that sewer utility is run so in
that there is an option for any
person to um ask for a waiver from that
100 foot requirement to have to connect
in and my experience in New Hampshire
with most communities is is that if
there is an established public super
sewer system and they're expanding and
there are properties that have currently
private septic systems the majority of
the time they do not require that they
connect until their septic system
actually fails so if you have a properly
functioning and working septic system
you do not have to connect until it
fails and then they would like you to
connect instead of building another
septic system so we oppose because it
conflicts with existing statutes it
erodes local Authority who have
established the guidelines for
connecting and they have a process to
opt out through their waiver process
each Community does things a little bit
differently in in New Hampshire we have
local control local sewer use ordinances
so I'll turn it over to Brandon for
drinking
water um good afternoon Brandon kernin
I'm the administrator of the drinking
water and groundwater Bureau and I just
want to express some concerns about this
bill relative to groundwater and
drinking drinking water protection um
first of all um as explained in the bill
already an entity a homeowner can opt
out of a water system if they're able to
site a well that meets our well sighting
and Wastewater disposal requirements
what house bill 1576 would do though is
introduce a waiver and even suggest that
you could monitor other people's um
groundwater quality if you can't meet
those requirements so you could put a
well in septic system in closer to Wells
than what our regulations allow now and
and as an offset monitor water quality
to see if anything goes bad we think
that's pretty risky and it's also really
unmanageable for the dees how would we
be able to track all these site specific
waivers and we certainly aren't funded
for that type of activity right now um
another concern is uh with the bill is
that it would require when there's new
water line that there be access points
or main stops or curb stops put in for
each property as the water line um
proceeds and while that is proactive and
trying to think about how to be very
efficient penetrating a water man is
more than you need to is one of the last
things you want to do it creates a weak
point an area where leakage would occur
or more likely and and even with the
valves um where those would need
maintenance over time um tapping a a
water main is a routine activity and so
while it's proactive to think about
putting these in water systems are fine
with putting them in on a case-by casee
basis opposed to just doing it for every
property and the last thing I just point
out is that the fine is pretty
significant for these Water Systems um
these water systems are either run by
elected officials or or regulated by by
Department of energy Public Utilities
Commission and there's lots of
opportunity for the public to intervene
and provide input and change things if
they don't like the rules of that
specific
utility that I'd be happy to answer any
questions Vice chair Thomas has
questions for you thank you thank you Mr
chairman thank for thank you for taking
my question so um just out of curiosity
here in New
Hampshire would there be is there is
there a mechanism a reasonable mechanism
for someone to live off the grid if they
if they so chose wherever they wanted
to they could live off the grid and if
they didn't have pressurized water that
or waste water then they wouldn't need
these approvals um if they wanted to
have pressurized water supply to a
building that they were in then they
would have to comply with our well
sighting and waste water disposal
requirements so
follow follow up okay so in effect then
if someone did want to live off the grid
they would be limited to where they
could live off the
grid correct they if they wanted a water
supply and a Wastewater Disposal system
they would have to to comply with State
and if applicable local
regulations I I just like to add I'm not
sure what you mean by I I know what you
mean by live off the grid but live off
the grid that they don't have any access
to water or sewer or I mean because to
live to occupy a dwelling you would need
a a building occupancy permit from any
Community you can't
just live occupy a property have a
building without proper public or water
and sewer can be private you can have a
private septic
system she say
me go ahead and answer it then well I
I'm I'm not sure but what what your your
question seems to imply
that uh somebody would have to get
special permission from the state if
they wanted to live off the grid is what
your question is kind of implying that
then I wouldn't say from the state I
would say from the local town the town
would have because you would need an
occupancy permit for a your property for
your building um and in order to get
that you have to have water and sewer
access to Water and Sewer I just
reiterate there are some communities at
least there were last time I looked that
don't require occupancy permits so
they'd be probably easy to live off the
grid if you didn't want pressurized
water waste water and lived in a town
that didn't require that
permit okay thank
you representative Bernardi has a
question thank you Mr chairman so uh I'm
GNA approach this from a from a
different angle my understanding of the
desire of this bill is that you live in
a community you have a well you have
sewer on your own your own
septic now down the road that you live
on someone's putting a development in
down the road Road they're going to run
a sewer line and a water line across the
front of your property to get to that
new development because you are on that
road they're going to now make you
abandon your well abandon your sewer and
sign
up that's what this thing I this this
legislation is trying to say no we need
to fix that state law that requires that
and not require that are you opposing
that principal or
not state law RSA 149 I requires each
town to have a local sewer use ordinance
so the statute requires the sewer use
ordinance the town develops their own
sewer use ordinance and that is approved
through their their town meeting
approval process or it has been
so it is up to that town whether they
required or not it's not up to
follow up follow up so the principle I'm
asking is shouldn't the state be law be
changed to not allow the town to mandate
that new line coming down in front of my
house all you know I'm on three acres
everything's fine I don't need a uh I
don't need to sign up for the system but
that development down the street is
causing those lines to be run shouldn't
the state law say the town can't do that
to
me I guess my opinion would be do we
want the state telling towns about their
towns each town is unique and they may
have their own individual reasons for
requiring things you know there's
certain communities that are dealing
with P contamination and they may have a
valid reason for wanting people to
connect to the Sewer um there's
communities that um have to abide by the
Great Bay total nitrogen General permit
um there's the ms4 permit there are all
these permits out there and that are
unique to each individual community and
I think my opinion would be that I the
local community should be deciding
what's best for their Community Based on
all of the requirements that they have
to meet knowing exactly what's going on
in their Community my experience has
been in that particular
circumstance it is rare that a community
would require someone to connect just
cuz they're running by on the sewer side
they would say if you have a functioning
septic
system you can keep that but once your
septic system fails we're going to
require you to connect if you're within
100 ft now because it's a local sewer
use ordinance communities can decide
they can make that distance longer some
can say 200 ft some may say 300 ft it's
it's up to that individual Community as
to what they
require representative lii has a
question thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question um since this is
new legislation would it not supersede
the uh statute that you quote here it be
an addendum to them because it's it
would
supersede I am definitely not a lawyer
and I I would recommend that you get um
an opinion on that um but the the
RSA that it's referencing is has nothing
to do with sewers so it's the wrong RSA
so I think you'd have to correct the RSA
to supersede the actual
RSA representative reos has a question
thank you Mr chairman um your um de's
written
testimony um talks somewhat extensively
about how the
economics
of public Municipal Water Systems and
sewer systems
are premised or
calculated
uh both from a capital investment
perspective and also from an operating
perspective so Capital costs would be
about the bond amount and the repayments
SCH for the bond and and operating would
be about the rates that all the
customers pay um this bill seeks to
begin to allow people to opt out of the
municipal systems is in your opinion
would this bill create um risk that
Municipal systems water and sew systems
which you know
are paying you know 30-year Bonds on on
upgrades and they're obviously uh
operating and and set their rates
probably annually that there would be a
de destabilizing effect if customers
start to drop off the municipal
systems thank you for your question yes
that's correct so when a wastewater
treatment facility is designed it's
based on lows and loadings and how much
is coming in and they're designed around
that how big are your tanks
um what processes are you going to use
and that's dictated by your effluent
permit limits you know so the whole
design of a Waste Water treatment
facility is very complex and it's costly
as we know um so yes that is based on
the number of users when they're looking
at how that's going to impact their
rates moving forward and you know if we
can all start from a a clean slate right
you know when you go into a community
and if you didn't have anything you
would be looking at the community and
you would say well how much existing
development do we have what do we think
we're going to have in the next 20 years
and you're going to design around all of
that um so that's what communities do so
it's very important um you know if we
want affordable rates in the state of
New Hampshire we get that by increasing
the number of users and I think
sometimes there's a misconception that
septic systems are so much cheaper than
it is to be on a municipal system but if
you think about a septic system the
going rate right now for a new system is
$25,000 and technically they last about
20 years maybe 25 if you're lucky so if
you spread that out over that period of
time you're paying basically $1,000 a
year for a septic system plus you need
to have it pumped every couple of years
and where does that need to go to a
wastewater treatment facility septic
systems do not exist without a
wastewater treatment facility so all of
those costs go into that we have to
remember that so when you think how much
you pay for your annual sewer bill I
know mine's getting up there right and
I've had the luxury of having a private
setic system but I also had to pay to
replace it so the costs are very very
equal over time when you when you put
them out and I think that the benefits
of having public sewers and being able
to connect to them is very important
because if we think about emerging
contaminants and the all the things we
don't know you know and what's the next
emerging contaminant and when you have a
private septic system you think you're
doing all the right things but then
something comes out like that horrible
four-letter word past and no one was
doing the right thing so you know public
sewers provide a purpose we're living
longer lives because we have public
sewers there's all good things come from
public sewers so I can't I can't stress
them enough you're
welcome cheerleader for public sews
representative Thomas has a question
thank you Mr chair hold on one second
sorry
okay um I I don't necessarily believe
that the intent behind this bill is a
bad idea I mean I'm hearing some
objections to it but I'm also hearing
that you know people shouldn't be forced
however if someone opts out of water due
to a private well situation like we have
in marac um would there be and I asked a
similar question earlier would there be
protections for that household's water
and I understand that homeowners are
respons responsible for testing their
water however if you're not aware of the
situation if you don't know what
contaminants to test for then you don't
know so if this bill passed would there
be some kind of a water protection for
the people that opt out education or
testing or something to make sure
they're doing the right thing for their
family thank you for the question so
right now you know if they opted out
they'd be drilling a well and working
with a licensed well driller who we work
with very closely when they drill Wells
to encourage testing and what the test
for and if you go type be well informed
on the internet search engine New
Hampshire you'll see all of our
resources on how to do that there have
been legislative initiatives the last
couple years to say whenever you drill a
new well you need to test it for certain
parameters that hasn't passed so far
what has passed is real estate
conveyance doc language and I think it
has to go the Senate still but the
mandate to test every time you put a new
well that has not made it through the
legislature today but has been
considered several times it should be I
would remind members they need to be
recognized to the by the chair before
they speak thank
you okay further
questions seeing none want to thank the
two of you for being here and answering
our questions about this bill now we'd
like to get a utility perspective as
Michael Lata from eversource would like
to speak to us about this
proposed
legislation uh thank you very much for
the opportunity to testify Michael Lata
representing
eversource uh we are opposed to the bill
uh I do appreciate uh the sponsor
statement about removing electric from
the scope of the bill that's something
we would certainly support uh eversource
does own Aquarian water and we do
provide water services to customers in
eight communities um we are a little
uncomfortable with uh some of the the
sort of Il defined terms um in the bill
uh which is why we we are opposed uh I
think the Department of Environmental
Services certainly did a good job
talking about uh Municipal ordinances as
it relates to to sewer um some of the
terms you know terminate connection
exactly what that means is that a
physical severing of a line is that just
turning off the water meter so that the
the customer no longer has Service uh
capping of access point uh exactly what
does that mean is that sort of a a stub
off of a main that's that's sort of
abandoned unless a customer uh wants to
access it is it um you know a junction
Point that's available in the future is
it just the ability to uh to provide
that access to the Future um and then on
the um second page of the bill line
1B um uses the term not shall not coers
fee shall not coers Property Owners to
opt in um you know coers is is sort of
uh I would say undefined uh a high fee
could be seen as coercion to one a
person uh could be seen as that's simply
the cost to provide service to another
um so uh I'll stop there but uh we do
have some uh concerns from both an
electric and water standpoint uh with
the legislation and I'll do my very best
to answer questions I'll just note I am
not an expert in water issues or energy
for that matter okay thank you questions
for Mr Lata representative Thomas thank
you Mr chair um could you just repeat
the name of the water company that you
work with Aquarion Aquarion thank you
representative Corman has a question
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr Lata
so um I'm actually pursuing the same
inquiry that I was uh asking the sponsor
so I'm thinking about this uh section
four with the the penalty to a utility
and I'm wondering how eversource views
that and and its application yeah uh
that's certainly a concerning part of
the bill to us especially as I described
sort of some of the IL defined um other
requirements certainly we want you know
very clear uh statute very clear rules
if if the potential for a fine is a
quarter of a million
dollars thank you seeing no further
questions we'll thank Mr Lata and next
call on Nate Graves of the New Hampshire
Municipal Association to give us his
perspective good afternoon welcome back
to stn thank you thank you Mr chair uh n
GES for the municipal Association we do
oppose this legislation um I will not
repeat anything that has been said by
any other stakeholders today except to
say that we agree with all of the points
already made um I want to answer first
um representative corman's question
about uh the rates I don't know how it
works in for private utilities but in
the case of municipally owned utilities
often what you have is a village
District which is a special basically
special type unit of government um that
operates for the purpose of providing
either electric water or sewer um and
these Village districts
raise taxes they pay for it through
taxes that the rate payers and the
taxpayers are the same um so in the case
of any of them being assess any
penalties basically what You' be doing
is penalizing the rate payers cuz
they're the ones who would come up with
all the money and then they would
basically get that money kicked back to
them in in the form of a lower bill so
it's kind of a circle um in the case of
of those minus whatever would qualify as
um the harm to the property owner who
was AG grieved by their inability to opt
out um I don't exactly know how that
would function so I I'm not exactly sure
how that would work um we're also
concerned about
um the the changes to existing statutes
as the chair noted um there there are
different chapters um for water
Wastewater and electric and this is all
combining them all into one each of
those have different parameters now I
think a more appropriate approach would
to any changing any one of those or all
three would be to uh to alter the
existing stand statutes as Dees noted um
147 colon 8 um requires a sewer
connection where the occupied building
is 100 ft from the uh from the sewer
line and there's a local option to
change that amount increase that amount
past 100 ft um as Dees noted in almost
all cases I'm not aware of any
exceptions but I hate to say always um
the what the the municipality has
adopted as a rule is if you already have
a well you can stay on your well if you
have a septic uh system that's
functioning you can keep that until it
um until it stops functioning there may
be exemptions so I don't say always but
that's generally the case um and one of
the concerns um that we would obviously
have is we have numerous areas of the
state which have groundwater
contamination through various sources um
whether that's uh you know arsenic
whether that's pasas whether that's a
different contaminant um and one of the
things that you do see sometimes is if
you have a number of Wells which are
currently clean a new line U
particularly a water line is run down a
road
um I'm sorry yeah a number of water of
Wells that are currently uh clean
testing clean but near that contaminated
at site if you have a new larger well Dr
drilled or another um interaction with
that groundwater you can actually see
that contamination plume change um so
what you often see in the case of um
private Wells is they'll have some sort
of additional treatment system Ro
filters for instance at my house because
you never know exactly how that
groundwater is going to change over time
and the testing only gives you a point
in time um examin of
that um I'm happy to take any questions
the committee may have um for
me okay thank you Mr Grace any
questions seeing none I'll thank you for
your testimony and ask the last person
who has signed up to speak on this bill
Griffin Roberge from the Department of
energy to give us his take on this
proposed
legislation and before he begins I want
to alert members of the committee that
throughout the afternoon this afternoon
OS will be delivering to US amendments
to bills that we will be executing
tomorrow so as they come in we'll be
passing them out to members of the
committee so you may have already seen
an amendment to House Bill
1036 there will be others coming um
House Bill 1700 House Bill
1697 House Bill
1078 um possibly one other so just keep
your eye open for those amendments and
make sure you hang on to them you'll
need them tomorrow and with that I'll
turn it over to you Mr robers thank you
Mr chairman uh again for the record
Griffin Roberge New Hampshire Department
of energy my comments will be uh fairly
brief um our position on the bill is
opposed and it's largely been expressed
by those who uh spoke previously um you
know I think we would be be very welcome
to the fact if the electric and gas
Provisions uh in this bill were removed
and I believe that was the intention of
the Prime sponsor um and with that
really just kind of happy to take any
questions if folks have them but please
know um water and sewer is certainly not
my Lane either um and if need be I will
follow up if I
can representative parshall has a
question thank you chair o and thank you
uh for testifying uh this is a question
that I really don't think you want to
answer I'll understand that but I've
been waiting for somebody to come up and
speak about uh the potential hazards of
when septic uh systems fail yeah the CNL
bacteria that they release into the
environment I have coming from the
Finger Lakes region of New York State
I've seen entire Lakes devastated by
this and um I would have enjoyed asking
this question of somebody else would
this regulation have an impact on the
release of Ceno bacteria into our
environment and I don't know was a good
answer I would
this um I am not in I am do not work for
Dees I would say it might be fair to
assume that that's as far as I'm going
to go with that thank you very much
representative Miss wood would you like
to answer representative parshall's
question
since you're here anyway you made the uh
the long Trek down from Hazen drive or
whatever so yes yes a very long
drive so your question is as far as
septic systems go and their
functionality and when they um are no
longer functioning as intended yes they
can if they're not you know once they've
reached their their useful life in the
leech field is I'm not a I'm not a a
septic system expert except for I've had
one I've had to build one I sit next to
Phil who oversees them at Dees but yes
improperly operated or um not built
sized properly can have negative impacts
to our water bodies I think in New
Hampshire we're seeing a lot of um C
cyanobacteria
outbreaks um you know can be devastating
to our our water bodies and any of us
that live in New Hampshire I think we
all live here for the same reason it's
because we love the outdoors and we want
to spend our time on our lakes and
rivers and you know we really need to
make sure that you know as Citizens that
we have properly operating and
functioning septic system so we don't
have negative impacts to our water
bodies does that answer your question
thank you it does uh I I could follow up
more but I I'll leave it at that and
thank you for coming back and answering
that question sure yes thank you
for and answering that question and
since there don't appear to be any more
and no one else has signed up to speak
on this bill I'm going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 17 uh
1576 and we will commence a public
hearing on House Bill 1600 FN in four
minutes stand
by
she
okay ladies and gentlemen welcome back
time to get back to work here and I'm
going to open a public hearing on House
Bill 1600
dfn relative to participation in net
energy metering and I'm going to call on
the prime sponsor of this legislation
representative Tom Corman to introduce
this bill to the
committee all yours Tom oh thank you
chair oose I am Tom Corman I represent
Grafton 15 which is the city of Lebanon
ward 3 and this is actually a bill
requested by one of my ward 3
constituents that constituent happens to
be the honorable Clifton Belo who is
chair of the community power Coalition
of New Hampshire uh before I get into
the particulars of the bill I do want to
say that the Coalition will be
introducing an amendment through me that
will make uh two changes one is to
eliminate section two of the bill so uh
all things being equal I'd rather not
even take questions on section two
because we expect to amend that out and
then uh another change will be a slight
change in the wording to section one the
the new wording that is inold in line
10 through 14 of section one will be
crafted as a separate sentence to
clarify it so what I'd like to focus on
in my very brief testimony before uh Mr
Belo speaks is what section one will do
and section one is going to say or does
say that if we have a municipal host
that is used to offset the load of a
municipal or County aggregation for
example the community power Coalition um
then it will go uh not on default
service so that the net metering would
be going toward the aggregation so for
example if um if we have a municipal
host that is who's uh production is
going to a community power Coalition or
Community power aggregation then that
net metering is going there and not on
default service and the beauty of this
is that we're always concerned about
cost shifting to default service service
and in this case there would be no cost
shift to default service so that's the
the big advantage of this and um with
that I'm happy to take questions but I
think any questions that you're going to
ask me are really much better answered
by Mr Belo but I'm willing to sit here
and and take
questions okay thank you does anybody
want to ask a question of Representative
Corman thank you for that very able
introduction to House Bill 1600 FN next
I'll call on The Honorable Clifton Belo
of the or representing the community
power Coalition of New Hampshire to tell
us why he thinks this bill is necessary
good afternoon Clifton good afternoon Mr
chairman members of the committee um I
am here on behalf the community power
Coalition of New Hampshire which has
grown to 55 about to be 56 members with
the addition of Hollis um that has
executed their
jpa um and we also welcomed uh the town
of epine into the Coalition uh just last
week um I'm here to urge you to support
a report of ought to pass with Amendment
um as described by representative Corman
um the reason uh we would uh are are
asking for this bill and and U urge your
support is that it provides needed
Clarity that group net metering programs
with Municipal host at the scale of 1 to
5 megaw can be developed for Community
power aggregations in alignment with
existing statutory requirements um the
the current definition of Municipal host
includes language that it's um used to
offset the electricity requirements of a
group consisting exclusively or one or
more customers or political subdivisions
and then there's a definition of
political subdivisions in the statute
that's that's in the bill existing
language L 7 through 10 um and that
definition includes any District or
entity created for special purpose
administered or funded by any of the
above named governmental units like a
municipality or County and uh we are a
special purpose entity um created uh
pursuant to a joint Powers agreement um
that is pursuant to RSA 53a which is a
statute that explains how uh
subdivisions of the state and agencies
the state can exercise authorities and
powers that are granted uh to them by
the legislature uh jointly with other
public agencies or subdivisions of the
state and the that RSA 53a characterizes
what um The Joint Powers agreement as a
an agreement that explains how uh a
program would be jointly administered
and that's exactly what we're doing uh
so just to be clear Community power
aggregation Municipal County aggregation
could be either operated within a
municipality um as an Enterprise fund
that's expressly allowed or jointly
through Community power Coalition or in
in other ways as well uh but the point
being I guess that um when we read the
law we think that we qualify as a
potential entity For Whom the power
would be offset and uh but in order to
have Clarity in this law we are
proposing uh in order to actually use
this as an offset um that there be a
requirement in in this instance for this
application uh that the uh customer
generator be a customer of the community
power aggregation and receive its
compensation from the aggregation rather
than the utility default
service um there is some language in
here that gives an example of a like a
water utility you know to just sort of
help think through how this uh apply but
I'll just sort of uh for the sake of
brevity skip over that and point to the
fact that RSA 6 362 A9 uh which is
referenced at line 13 of the bill uh
provides that municipal or County
aggregations under 53e May determine the
terms conditions and prices under which
they agree to provide generation Supply
to and credit as an offset to supply or
purchase the generation output exported
to the distribution grid from eligible
customer generators and goes on to say
such output shall be accounted for as a
reduction to the customer generators
electricity suppliers wholesale load
obligation um so it's sort of the idea
if we get some of our power locally from
uh uh uh a municipal host that that
actually helps serve uh the load of
members of the community power
aggregation um this is consistent with
longstanding New Hampshire policy um I
would point in particular to the fact
that from the very original enactment of
net metering law in 1998 it expressly
provided that uh electricity suppliers
May voluntarily determine the terms
conditions and prices under which they
agree to provide generation Supply to
and purchase net generation output from
eligible customer generators and the
enactment of net metering um included an
update to the purpose statute of the
overall chapter saying that uh the goals
of the chapter which uh upon enactment
also included uh net metering should be
pursued in a competitive environment
pursuant to the restructuring policy
principls set forth in RSA
374f so um this is really a way to open
up um right now all Municipal hosts are
going through the utility default
service and they're getting paid the
full default service rate um but it can
actually be used it's not actually being
used to actually offset the load of
individual customers um uh necessarily
um but this would create a framework in
which this could occur um and do so in a
way that does not uh increase uh
stranded cost or or cost shifting um uh
so and that is simply because they would
not be on utility default service so the
utility wouldn't be paying them any
compensation for their energy output and
we would be a pain for that from our own
customers because it's being used to
serve offset part of their load um
um do want to be clear that the intent
is to uh clarify and clearly enable this
novel option I say it's novel because it
hasn't been done before um it's not
intended to supplant amend or limit
existing group net metering Arrangements
uh that typically involve them or in all
cases involve the municipal hosts uh
being a customer of utility default
service so that they get paid that
default service rate
um with members um that consist of
individual ret retail customer accounts
um so there on the last page of my
written testimony in the middle italics
there is a suggestion uh on proposed new
language uh that could uh substitute for
the language on on pages on uh lines 10
through 14 of the bill um just reading
when a municipal host consents to use
its generation to offset the group load
of a municipal or County aggregation and
not individual retail customer accounts
then it shall be a customer of a
municipal or County aggregation and not
on utility default service with
compensation for their output made
pursuant to RSA 362 A9 Roman 2 so that
that's the basic notion and just a quick
word about part two of the bill it was
intended to help maximize the value of
net meter Generation by treating them as
load reducers rather than I and wingland
Market participants currently about 51
out of
some
16,000 net metered uh customer
generators uh do simultaneously sell
their power into the ice New England
Market create some jurisdictional
questions but those issues are currently
being considered at the Pu in their net
metering uh proceeding looking at
updating uh terms conditions and tariffs
for net metering uh particularly for
those customers on utility default
service so it's appropriate uh to delete
section to the bill and allow the Pu to
consider those issues in that
proceeding um so that's that's basically
it and I thank you for your attention
and interest in the bill well thank you
so the the last statement you made about
deleting section two of the bill
M because there's an ongoing docket at
the Public Utilities Commission about
net metering yes when you testified
earlier this year on House Bill
1398 you stated that we shouldn't make
any changes to net metering law until
that docket is
completed but now you're here suggesting
that we should change uh net metering
law before that docket is completed can
you shed some light on why you believe
it's okay to do it here where it wasn't
okay to do it on HB 1398 well um House
Bill
1398 changed how exports to the the uh
the compensation paid to net meter
customers by the utility uh would be
treated as but I'd like you to comment
on your suggestion that we need to wait
until that docket is finished before we
change net metering law again um well I
don't I I guess I don't really recall
saying we shouldn't make any changes uh
to the net metering law this is this
what's presented in part one of the bill
is not uh something that's really it
that's not it's not in any way pending
before the commission currently it's not
an issue that was in any way noticed in
their uh order of notice and so and and
it's also too late to you know besides
the fact that it's beyond the scope of
the current net metering docket so in
that sense
um you know to to not act on section one
of the bill just puts puts that issue
off and uh creates a situation where the
only option for new Municipal host is is
to go onto utility default service and I
would just note that there are scores
literally scores of potential projects
in the interconnection queue in the 1 to
5 megawatt range and so just as an
example why why I think this would be
beneficial to to act now on this the
city of Lebanon will go online sometime
later this year with a one megawatt
landfill gas to energy project it it
will produce as much power as a a 4
megawatt PV system because of its high
capacity Factor
um it will produce more than enough to
offset the entire City's load as well as
probably the school district's load um
so we could sign it up with traditional
group net metering the way it is now it
could also be bigger than one megawatt
because we have a lot of solar that we'd
like to put behind the same meter point
so we could qualify as a municipal host
and and then get the full utility
default service while in fact those same
customers uh those governmental entities
within our community are actually paying
substantially less because they've
switched over to Lebanon Community power
which is which is less and then all
those cost of paying out um at the full
utility default service rate would end
up being uh cost that under the current
structure get shifted to other customers
potentially through a uh something like
a strain of cost recovery charge if on
the other hand uh we had this option and
there was Clarity on it um uh the city
of Lebanon you know we've all talked
about it we would rather prefer that
output um go to offset the load of the
aggregation as a whole and we believe
that we can work out a reasonable
compensation Arrangement such that that
makes makes sense for both the city and
Lebanon Community power which which is
in effect a program of the city um so
and and in that structure uh because we
would be looking at an arrangement that
provided stable income for the city to
you know offset its cost of putting in
the landfill gas to energy project all
those costs would be recovered from
within Lebanon Community power so here's
an option to to bring online that new
resource and have it serve in such a way
that it doesn't ask the default utility
to cover any of the cost for that output
and and therefore those costs are not
costs that they have to look at
recovering from all rate payers um so so
I think there's a practical application
of where passing this now creates a
situation where where we can actually do
something to avoid any additional cost
shifting and yet enable this project to
go forward and and and ser benefit the
community absent this we'll go the
traditional net metering route and just
take take the money but this this would
be a better arrangement I think okay
thank you so having signed the joint
Powers agreement for the town of eping
I'm aware that
currently customers or citizens and
eping who do net metering have to stay
on default service they can't move to
eping community power can you explain to
me exactly why they can't do that um
there's two issues why that they can
move it's just that we are we can't
compensate them for their output and
there's two reasons for that one is
we're not
getting regular
or uh consistent report reporting from
the utilities on what those exports to
the grid are um they they report zero
when a customer exports power to the
grid to a competitive supplier or CPA
what they report to us is zero so we
don't even know what those experts to
the grid are so how can we even begin to
think about compensating them that's one
problem now to be clear two of the
utilities uh eversource and Unitil have
said they'll start giving us quarter
reports after the fact that does detail
detail what those exports are um uh
Liberty has said they'll do that but
they haven't gotten around to it yet
they haven't been able to reproduce that
report so we're still in the dark as to
what uh and some net meters net meter
customers did decide to come over
anyways even though they lose their
credit the other reason which is a
really big reason is um is the
language um that I point
to um at the bottom of page two of my
testimony in the top of Page Three it's
really the top of Page
Three that does say such output shall be
accounted for as a reduction to the
customer generator's electricity
suppliers wholesale load
obligation um n of applicable line loss
adjustments as approved by the
commission that right now none of the
utilities all four of them including the
co-op none of them currently have a have
a load settlement system that allows
them to take into account exports to the
grid um we need that to happen we need
to uh uh Implement that law we are
preparing we we've been talking with the
three investor own utilities about this
uh we actually have another meeting with
them tomorrow afternoon to continue our
discussions about how to achieve this uh
but the long and short of that is we we
need um uh we need to have that
implemented so such such that we're in a
position to compensate the customer
because we're getting some value from
them and that value being their exports
to the grid being counted as an offset
to what we otherwise would have to buy
uh from ISO New England um so those are
the two parts that we need to uh sort of
fix or get in place in order for us to
be able to serve net beer customers and
and be able to give them credit for
their experts to the
grid thank you other questions for Mr
Belo representative McGee has one thank
you Mr chairman thank you Mr vo um I
want to follow on to what you just said
about those two two issues so how far
are we or how far are the utilities from
being able to provide that that load
settlement Shore
up I where where are we at I mean that's
I can't really say I mean the utilities
could speak to that better than I could
um essentially what they've said is you
know they this this this notion was also
reflected in the pu's rules um and in
that um
uh so it's both in the rules and the law
but it's still does require the Pu to
make a determine as to what line loss
factor to work into that uh formula if
you will be because there is when you're
offsetting load on the distribution grid
there's still some line loss because you
from a physics point of view you will
offset the sort of the nearest load and
if your big system it may be the whole
circuit or back up to the sub Sub
Station if you're small system it maybe
just your neighbor's load behind the
same Transformer so there's a loss
Factor there that is somewhat smaller
than the loss factor to get all the way
up to the regional transmission grid um
which involves losses from uh
substations and step down from 345 KV
down to distribution voltage so so that
that needs to be resolved but once
that's resolved
um as near as we can tell the utilities
haven't really planned for this and and
basically they're saying it's a big IT
project to change their systems to
implement this we don't know that that's
the case we're trying to sort of fact
find and we we H are finding that there
are uh load Settlement Services that
take into account exports to the grid so
it's not it's not a novel thing in terms
of load settlement it's just apparently
novel in New
Hampshire and just followup followup so
it sounds like that piece might be under
the pu's purview to try and make those
determinations and figure that out with
the utilities but back to the piece that
you referred us to in the italicized uh
paragraph on page four of your testimony
yes that is what the amendment which I
think is being handed around now uh is
that the piece that the amendment tries
to resolve with this bill
today um I don't know I haven't seen
this amendment oh the amendment that's
circulating is not related to this this
a different amendment I don't have you I
don't have the amendment on 1600 so I'm
not in talking with representative of
Vos um last week um he indicated this
bill's not for executive or work session
tomorrow um so there's a little bit of
time to get this and quite honestly this
was a bit of a negotiation with
particularly the grant State Hydro
Association which is mainly represents
about 40 of these generators who are
simultaneously selling the iso New
England market and participating in net
metering and they they they uh had a
indicate a strong preference for this
issue not to be addressed in this bill
uh but rather you know at the Pu where
where where the issue is being
adjudicated as as part of other things
representative Ms has a question thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question I just want to follow up on the
question from um our chair um this bill
doesn't do anything to address that
issue with
individual um net metered customers does
it
no no um and in fact this this bill
wouldn't do anything uh
for the Lebanon landfill Gas Energy
project as an example and and there's
many others many of our communities have
sites that they are suitable for 1 to
five megawatt projects that they'd like
to see develop potentially to serve the
community power aggregation um but that
load settlement issue has to be
separately resolved um and I think
that's just a matter of time through the
Pu processes but once once that occurs
then it would create this as a real
possibility obviously from our point of
view we'd like to see that resolved in a
matter of months and not years but but
that remains to be seen followup
followup so so which um which entities
this is this going to affect or
benefit um I I think it would benefit
rate paays in general because more
projects under the municipal host rubric
would not some of those projects may not
go on to you IL default service creating
those those costs there um and then it
potentially benefits any Community power
aggregation program that has enough load
that could be matched and offset uh by a
local uh project it it would have to be
a local project because in the current
um load settlement system you need to
settle all the load within the
boundaries of what's called a load asset
ID number which is the iso New England
uh terminology for
uh how loads get settled so you know for
Lebanon Community power just as an
example um our our loads currently only
positive loads but those get settled in
a unique load asset ID that's unique to
the city of Lebanon um uh Lebanon
Community power so the generator would
need to be part of that um to be to be
used to offset that load so that you
could take those exports to the grid and
essentially subtract them out of the
load and um and and thereby um you know
determine your actual net
load I I I I should mention what's
happening to all those exports now it
ends up in a bucket called unaccounted
for energy lit literally it's not being
accounted for literally the utilities
told me or at least eversource did that
they could not um uh come up with a
comprehensive um uh data data set for
what the exports to the grid are by net
metered customers even though they have
that somewhere in their system they just
said it was Impractical to do they can't
extract that data and after pressing
them they did finally extract it for the
seven largest and for and for 10 hydros
and for 10 PV systems that have interval
metering uh but but we'd hope to be able
to look at you know the data for all 51
of these uh generators that sell into
the iso New England Market to understand
that particular issue but um they're
they're systems are constrained and what
they can extract from them
apparently representative Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair um both and
thank you for being here as always um
both you and the prime sponsor have said
that you're going to remove section two
just for clarification yes is that line
15 through 28 and we're just correct
we're just taking that all out correct
okay thank
you representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chair
so my question is back to the bill
because we've covered a lot of what
isn't that we can't fix with the bill
that we're not going to fix with the
bill uh so I think some of the language
might be a little um hard to follow for
some folks so I I wrote this down and
I'm I'm wondering if this might be uh a
way to look at the essence of the bill
which is that the municipal host
generator shall now be a customer of the
aggregator and that then the aggregator
would provide compensation to them for
their power so that would be the that
would be the scenario that the bill
actually allows for is that correct yes
in the case where it's U the generator
consents to that meaning they're
agreeable to it um uh perhaps by a
contract if it's a third party uh or if
it's within house like the city's
project it would just do it because it's
approving that um and and and when in
that in that case where it's being used
to offset the aggregation load as a
whole and not individual customer counts
so followup followup and then the
followup would be then us placing this
in statute the reason to be doing this
would be to accommodate an alternative
to default service providers so that
it's clear in statute that that is
something that can happen and that the
relationship
between producers and off-takers that's
happening through that relationship will
also compensate those folks um and but
it doesn't involve any cost shifting
because it doesn't involve utilities and
default service right is that correct
correct uh representative Kaplan has a
question thank you Mr chair and thank
you Mr Belo for coming in this is kind
of a followup to representative McGee's
question I just need some clarification
on the benefit to the rate payers of
this new process where Municipal hosts
and Municipal aggregators can go through
the net metering instead of the default
service H can you explain how what that
benefit is because I'm not clear on how
the utilities are get are are accounting
for you say it's an unaccounted for
bucket so how do we know that they're
not accounting for for those costs
somehow and um well because they told us
they don't account for it um but it ends
up in this bucket called unaccounted for
energy- which which does go into
everybody's load settlement as an
adjustment factor to reconcile the the
difference between the meter wholesale
meter point and the retail meter points
I mean normally if you had no generation
on on the distribution grid the you
would you would be getting you would
take your um uh retail loads and you
would have to buy roughly 7% more um for
line losses so you know if you had a
th000 megawatts you need to buy
1,070 uh uh from um the bulk power
Market over the transmission grid to
serve that load um so but but so so what
happens now because they don't account
for these exports explicitly I mean they
do on individual customer bills they
know the numbers uh because they show it
on customer bills uh but but they don't
account for it in terms of load
settlement so what ends up happening is
that
um they have to adjust and we did we did
finally get you know I asked this
question in the last net metering
proceeding and I could you know didn't
get any good answers but this time
Unitil and eversource said even even
though they sort of publish and say that
the line losses are on the order of 7%
um in point of fact they ended up uh the
Delta between retail loads and wholesale
loads is only
4.4% um in last year in 2022 I should
say 2022 which and that's for 247 and of
course it varies by hour but what that
indicates and and they also what that
indicates is is that that unaccounted
for energy is a reducing the apparent
line losses so it reduces the amount of
power that each load serving entity has
to buy but basically nobody knows it
because that number is not published so
it it's sort of a bit of a black box as
to what happens to these exports to the
grid uh but but but they did concede um
at least two of the utilities in their
response on Discovery that certain hours
of the day like in the middle of a sunny
day it could appear here that we're
buying less power um to serve the load
than the actual load so if we're to
serve 100 kilowatt of load we're maybe
only buying 95 kilowatts of power and
obviously that's not true it's just that
it's not being separately accounted
for follow up follow up if I may uh yeah
so I mean there yeah there's a black box
in terms of the load and and the the uh
the Delta between what what they say
they're getting and when what what is
actually happening on the line but it's
also a black box in terms of how they
account for their costs um we've we've
learned that you know it's sometimes
recover through a stranded cost
mechanisms some sometimes it's default
and they're both under the net metering
rubric so I just want some clarity on
how this new program is actually going
to be a benefit to the rid payers um
well it's a potential benefit um like
I'll just give the example of of the
lebanon's landfill gas project it would
be a benefit because we would be
potentially locking in a long-term local
power resource at at a stable price that
will help with future volatility in our
rates um and and and um from our point
of view it produce a tremendous number
of renewable class one renewable energy
credits which we'd want to buy as a
package so for the St City you know it
provides a benefit because there we we
know that this
project that as a result of waste from
the City and surrounding community
communities is being cycled back to to
benefit the local rate
payers primarily in the form of stable
rates and and a attractive long-term
price for the renewable energy credits
uh it it and it may or may not have the
result of helping lower the actual cost
um over time I I think it tend to it it
will um but again the general the
general rate payers is not really at any
risk of that um and and even the Lebanon
rate payers aren't at risk because if it
turns out we make a bad decision and we
end up with an above Market contract
then customers are always free to leave
to go back to the utility to FSE service
or competitive
supplier representative rolds has a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Mr Belo for being here um I want to
Circle back uh to the way you described
this um the effect of this bill a little
bit earlier um a common a common
criticism of net metering in general
especially large scale net metering like
that contemplated in The Spill the 1 to
five megawatt customer generator is that
forcing the default utilities or yeah
the default utilities to purchase that
power at the retail rate you know is a
cost shift uh it's a it's a cost to all
rate payers
and you're saying that the effect of the
desire the goal of this bill is to
enable um a large scale Municipal
host to stop selling that
power to the default utility stop
forcing the default utility to pay
retail rate for their power and instead
be able to sell their output to a
municipal aggregator which very often or
perhaps always would be uh the
essentially the same body of red pairs
the same citizens is that correct is are
we addressing a criticism of of net
metering with this
bill um I think so I mean I mean there's
been opposition to opening up 1 to 5
megawatt projects precisely over that
concern this is a limited way to open
that up in a way that addresses that
concern you have a
followup followup
is it would it be correct to um to say
that
this making this
change is is necessary to to make our
the evolution of our utility
system internally consistent in other
words the legislature we passed a law
years ago to um allow the creation of
community power so that municipal alties
could take on that role of aggregating
and and acquiring their own
Supply
but under the laws that exist
now even though the it's the
municipality that that may act to build
a you know up to 5 megawatt system uh
generating system on their landfill they
can't be their own customer they have to
sell the ACT they have to uh sell the
output to a utility default utility to
derive any value from it it seems that
seems in uh contradictory to me so I
this feels like that this would be
making our our progression here in the
utility realm more consistent is that
correct I yes and just one thing to
point out is RSA 53e that uh enables
Community power
aggregations dating back to 19
96 1996 when it was first enacted says
the purpose is to provide uh customers
of Municipal and County aggregations
quote access to competitive markets for
supplies of electricity and related
services and to encourage voluntary
costeffective and innovative solutions
to local needs and and just to go back
to my example of the Lebanon landfill
gas that doesn't isn't just a better way
to Expos of the methane rather than just
flaring it because it we can produce
some value from it it's also an
important local resiliency resource
because we're going to configure it so
if the grid goes down it can have a
transfer switch and continue to operate
and we're putting in a level three
charging facility at that so the city
which owns electric vehicles could
charge its Vehicles particularly when we
get electric police vehicles in
emergency response Vehicles we could
have charged them through this landfill
gas project um uh uh even even if we had
an extended grid outage so that that's
just an example of it of an Innovative
solution to local needs that creates a
Synergy without having to create issues
around this increased cost
shifting thank you so we have six other
people who would like to testify on this
legislation so I'd like to move on but
before I let you go I want to follow up
on representative R's question earlier
in your testimony you said there were
scores of people lined up in the
interconnection Q uh between 1 and 5
megawatts uh for uh net
metering Municipal host net metering uh
programs would you say that we can
expect an explosion of net metering as a
result of all those scores of uh
customers lined up in the inter
connection queue um
I don't know because it's going to take
a while for them to be processed but you
know they're in the queue but a lot of
them still have studies that are going
it's taken us four years to get the
Lebanon landfill gas project fully
permitted for
interconnection um so I think a lot of
those have are some years out but also
there's limited opportunities and and I
think they're trying to position
themselves quite honestly for a
potential change in the legislative
environment where the legisl Fe just
opens up 1 to 5 megawatt for anybody
under existing terms I mean there have
been bills that have tried to do that in
recent years so um I I think that's part
of it I think there's hope that under
the existing Municipal host uh uh uh
construct that there was opportunities I
think at some point those will run out
because they will have signed up all the
customer accounts that are willing to
participate in that um so I I I would
whether this goes forward or or not I
expect to see continued pressure and
interest in in that sort of scale
project just because the economics get
better and better as you get into that
scale um which is another reason why we
think this could work for Community
power
aggregations um is is that at that scale
there's opportunities to strike a deal
that's going to make be favorable to
both
parties and really a market-based deal
at that point okay perfect thank you
very much The Honorable Clifton below
next I'll call on The Honorable Bill
babber to testify on this
bill former member of this committee and
a good friend of ours nice to see you
Bill welcome back nice to be back I
think I appreciate that kind remarks
um I just going to make some brief
remarks and support of this bill um and
they will be brief in a high level uh
like many of you I serve on a number of
community committees two frequently
expressed uh concerns we hear is how can
we effectively grow the local economy
and how do we restrain the cost of
electric power this bill helps address
those two issues as a former member of
this committee there were times when the
language details of the energy
legislation could be a bit mystifying I
will say this uh incarnation of the
committee seems to be doing a pretty
good job with that asking simple High
Lev questions worked well for me in
helping me reach a conclusion on a bills
fit to the state's need questions like
these will hb600 is drafted in the
proposed amendment move rates in a more
Equitable direction for customers I
believe it will will hb600 help address
the fastest growing portion of utility
bills transmission costs which are
already the nation's highest I believe
it will will hb600 enhance the state
Marketplace for Renewable Power and
local well-paying jobs and create
additional options for customers I
believe it will and um
following Clifton Belo is always
difficult so
I the mystery has preceded me but I
would be if you have any easier
questions I'd be happy to
answer well nevertheless we appreciate
your perspective uh as a well-respected
member of the
uh former legislative Community we uh
your opinion is always valuable to us
any questions for The Honorable Mr
babber seeing none I'll thank you and
move on to the next person I'd like to
call on Doria Brown from the city of
NASA representing the city of
nsha good afternoon uh Miss Brown Hello
nice to see you again it's nice to see
you
too um hi um my name is is Doria Brown I
am currently the energy manager for the
city of
Nashua uh in April of 2023 the city
launched our NASA Community power
program through the community power
Coalition of New
Hampshire yeah sorry about that
yeah better all right yeah yeah yes um
through the community power Coalition of
New Hampshire in the first seven months
of operation Nashville Community power
has generated 6.4 million in Total
Community Revenue with 3.3 million of
that in customer savings and 3.1 million
in community reserves the city of nsha
supports
hb600 with the inclusion of the
amendment strike of section two and
modification of section one as proposed
by representative Corbin we specifically
support this bill because it provides
CPAs with the needed Clarity around
Municipal host net metering at the scale
of 1 to 5
megaw can be developed for CPAs in a way
that allow for greater competition
flexibility and aligns with existing
state law the city of NASA's interests
in this are a little bit unique because
we own two hydroelectric dams on the
Nashua River Jackson Mill which is a 1
megawatt operation and Mine Falls which
is a 3 megawatt Operation we also have a
landfill Gas Energy plant at the Four
Hills landfill which has the potential
with our two hydroelectric facilities to
power about 40% of our community power
load so these projects support the
city's goal in achieving 100% renewable
energy resources by 2025 through the
potential of this project as well as
through being able to create micro grids
at our landfill gas to energy plant
which we're hoping to be able to have
something similar to what lebanon's goal
is which is a um electric vehicle
charging operation at that
site including these changes to the bill
would retain the flexibility that we
have under current structure which
allows our Hydro Dam to participate in
group net metering as a municipal host
and serve some individual Municipal
accounts while staying on utility Energy
service thank you for your time and
consideration of my testimony and I
welcome the opportunity to answer
questions than thank you Miss Brown good
to hear what uh the city of Nash is up
to representative McGee has a question
for you thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Miss Brown for taking my question
you mentioned that NASA had um recovered
6.4 million in Revenue I believe in the
last year can you just explain to us how
that's come in what it's related to so
we can understand yes where the benefits
are coming from so I said that we
created 6.4 million in community value
um Revenue would actually be higher than
that I think last time I looked at the
number was 11 million in Revenue so
Community value is the 3.3 million of
customer savings plus the 3.1 million of
community reserves which we've been able
to accumulate through our community
power program which will help offset
shifts in the energy Market as we work
on pricing as well as in the future be
able to go towards special projects um
that might be
uh programs like our Hydro electric
facilities or maybe even being able to
help invest in More Energy Efficiency
programs for our
community further questions for Miss
Brown representative muns has one thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question as a followup to representative
McGee H how would this bill change that
number would the the would the value
that you'd be the community the
community value go up down sideways what
would it do so if we were to have the
option of working in our hydroelectric
facilities as well as our landfill Gas
Energy facility with our community power
program we would be able to create a
more stable energy price from being able
to sell that to our community power
program so that value would be able to
increase and we'd be able to have more
consistency with our pricing so we can
put more money towards Reserve funding
so that we can hopefully have More
Energy Efficiency programs or more
renewable energy pro programs which
further drive down our cost creating
more Community
value okay additional
questions seeing none thank you Miss
Brown We Appreciate You trekking up here
to conquer to talk to us today next we'd
like to hear from Sam Evans Brown of
clean energy New Hampshire to get uh
clean energy New Hampshire's perspective
on this proposed legis ation good to see
you Sam welcome back thank you um and I
can be fairly brief we are also coming
to testify in support of the bill excuse
me for the record Sam Evans Brown
executive director of clean energy New
Hampshire um
we uh maybe to take just a step back I
think there from a from a broad sense uh
we see this as a very elegant approach
to uh open up a new way of attracting
private Capital to to build local
Generation Um net metering has been for
the the two decades that it's been in
place one of the only mechanisms that
are in place for rate payers to be able
to choose where they get their
generation from um but it has its
failings uh in order to be able to take
advantage of net metering you tend to
have to be a homeowner you tend to be
have to you tend to either have to have
capital or have access to Capital in
order to make investments in your own
Generation Um and this bill would solve
those types of problems and allow the
benefits the the cost saving reduction
the the bill savings to be spread more
broadly amongst all of the members of a
community power aggregation so we have
been working actively with the community
power coalition to just make sure the
language is crystal clear that this
doesn't step on or impinge at all in the
existing Municipal host uh program uh
there are municipal hosts that are up
and running right now and we just want
to make sure it's it's very clear that
you don't have to choose to use your
generation to offset the load of a CPA
if you're if you're a municipal host um
and and have had very fruitful
conversations with uh with the the folks
that have been involved in those and so
I think we will have um a really strong
bill that comes out of this that that
enables more folks to to access the the
cost savings that that net metering can
provide so would that would have you to
take questions or just recede into the
background you can never recede into the
background I
try questions for Mr everence Brown
seeing none I guess you're going to have
to recede but I'm sure it won't be to
the background okay next up is Matt
Milow or mle or Miller I can't quite
read the the um mat I'm Matt Miller
Miller Miller
Miller common of Pembrook welcome Mr
Miller yeah thank you Mr chairman in in
your committee uh yeah uh I
am turn it back on okay thank you yeah
um Matt Miller from pimbrook New
Hampshire representing myself um I do
volunteer for pimbrook on the uh energy
committee and in on their budget
committee and um I'm here to support uh
hb600 um last year March 2023 the town
of penber voted to approve an energy
aggregation plan enabling it to launch a
community power aggregation
and um the the town strongly supported
that it was virtually a unanimous um
vote in the during the last year's town
meeting um and our CPA will launch this
March um and uh the town's power
Community uh Community power aggregation
will benefit by having the ability to
access local energy sources of this
scale that we're talking about 1 to 5
megawatts through competitive markets
while avoiding this uh potential cost
shift um through the activities that
have already been described by previous
speakers um I had some comments about
the benefits of the second section which
uh mainly pointed towards load reduction
but since that sounds like it's being
written out that's that's fine if it's
addressed somewhere else uh that's the
only statement I wanted to make uh that
I support uh
hb600 well thank you very much thanks
for your time questions for Mr
Miller seeing none well thank you for
coming up to testify here today and move
on to Miss Heidi croll from the granite
state hydr Power Association to get her
perspective on this
legislation welcome back miss croll good
to see you good afternoon Mr chairman
and members of the committee um for the
record my name is Heidi croll I work at
Gallagher cahan gartell and I'm here
today on behalf of the Granite State
hydrop Power Association I too can be
very quick um we did have some concerns
with the bill as introduced but we um
appreciate the um conversations that
we've had with uh Clifton Belo and uh
clean energy New Hampshire and other
stakeholders and the willingness of the
Prime sponsor to um uh just clarify
section one um as you've heard just to
make sure that any existing um
Arrangements um between Municipal host
and Municipal um uh off-takers you know
that those existing Arrangements won't
be uh impacted and um also um removing
section two because we know that the Pu
docket is is underway so um I can be
very brief happy to answer any questions
but that's that's where we're at thank
you questions for Miss scroll seeing
none we'll move along thank you and call
next Barbara Southland I believe I hope
I got that
right from close
Bradford Barbara soued from Bradford
it's soued m okay sorry sorry I couldn't
quite make it out no problem a lot of
people have problems with it usually
it's South
word but anyway I just am REM
representing really myself but lots of
other homeowners who have invested in
solar I've we've got solar on our
rooftop and then across from our house
in the field a big array and we have
really enjoyed getting net metering we
get you know low we pay the minimum
every month and then even in the winter
time we get some credit so I think it's
great and uh uh but uh Bradford is
considering Community power we're voting
on that in March and I think it's
wonderful uh but um I'm told that we
can't do net metering we'll have to opt
out so I'm hoping that this bill will
correct that situation because I think
it's very
ironic that um Community Powers you know
the mission is to go towards clean
renewable energy and uh but we we can't
even participate as long as we have net
metering so uh I'm just please support
please vote for this bill and because I
think it would fix that problem
okay thank you very much questions from
s seeing none thank you very much thank
for your service for for trekking down
here to talk to us we appreciate it next
up is Griffin robers from the Department
of energy along with
Liz
Nixon thank
you hello again uh Griffin Roberge State
energy program manager at the department
of energy with me today is Elizabeth
Nixon electric director at Department of
energy and uh we are here uh our
comments will be relatively brief we
understand that there have been um a
number of amendments suggested to the
bill um we are neutral um on the bill as
introduced we understand as I mentioned
I understand that um there's been
amendments to strike section two into
modify the language in section one um we
are just learning about that Amendment
uh today so we'd like the opportunity to
go back review and then follow up the
with the committee later on with any
observations that we have and um that's
really it happy to take any questions
that folks might
have okay thank you questions for the
Department of energy representative
McGee has one thank you Mr chair I'll
try and formulate one this one is for
Miss Nixon um as a person who's working
in the electric electricity uh sector
for the state I'm just wondering about
the language that we discussed which is
going to remain in the bill which
obviously you haven't seen the amendment
yet but around the idea of Municipal
host generators being able to uh provide
their energy to community
aggregators and then being compensated
directly from from those entities rather
than default service do you have any
thoughts around that particular change
in the law as it would affect being
AnMed
customer um as Mr Rober said we just
learned of the change today and it was
unclear to us specifically how this
language was was meant to be so I guess
I'd Reserve um I'd like us to go back
and evaluate that and let you
know fair enough any further
questions seeing none I guess you guys
are
off the hook thank you and done so we'll
give the last word to M
friedricks of Durham representing 350 in
h hello
please be as brief as you can be thank
you m friedricks um from representing
both the town of Durham today and 350 NH
thank you for allowing me to speak um
from the uh the town side of things um
as a a town counselor um in Durham we
have heard a lot of requests um over the
past year or inquiries from residents um
asking about how they might be able to
benefit from something like a community
solar project um because they have
limitations on their own properties they
live in the shade um they uh have an old
roof they are renters um and so they're
very interested in being able to um to
have some of the um economic and and
health benefits of doing solar um but
they're not there's not currently a way
for them to do that um and uh our
understanding is that this bill would um
clarify and enable um the ability of
community solar um to occur through
something like the community power
Coalition of New Hampshire um Our Town
Administrator has stated that um you
know he would be uh certainly
comfortable with uh a Community solar
array um being supported through the
community power Coalition of New
Hampshire but is rather reluctant to
take that on otherwise um in terms of
the sighting and the the administrative
um duties of of running a community
solar field so this is something that
would really clearly benefit our
residents um and would be an enabling um
piece of legislation by clarifying that
language um and through my work on the
town I'm also aware of community solar
projects that are happening um in are
sort of the design stage or the concept
stage and at least another dozen other
communities across the state so I think
there's very clear interest in in trying
to make this an option that is available
to Residents um that has direct benefits
um to Residents uh if it is enabled and
um you know in from the standpoint of
350 NH um we actually have several
chapters across the state that are
working on community solar projects as
well so in many different areas we're
hearing of community interest in doing
this um and uh our understanding is that
this bill just clarifies um some
enabling language to make sure that
communities have that wish to pursue
this do have an option for it thank you
um questions for Miss
Friedrich seeing none I want to thank
you for trekking down here today to give
us your perspective on this legislation
now with that we're going to close the
public hearing on House Bill 1600 FN
and in about five minutes representative
Vice chair Thomas will open a public
hearing on House Bill 16 44 FN we'll see
you in five
minutes
okay I see it's the time to get started
uh I'm going to um ask uh representative
o to introduce uh HB 1644 FN which is
requiring the department of energy to
initiate an investigation of the
benefits and key considerations G
regarding support for clean or
non-carbon emitting emitting power
generation so with that representative o
the floor is
yours thank you Mr
chair for the record Michael Vose
representing Rockingham District 5 I've
introduced House Bill
FN as a way to
support or try to support I should say
electric generation that's
reliable for the last couple of years
I've been reading a lot of reports from
nerk from furk from ISO New England and
from other jurisdictional entities
around the country discussing the
increasing perception that our grid
Nationwide is becoming
unreliable there's also a that's been
written about our local grid here in ISO
New England becoming less
reliable reliability is an extremely
important subject to the constituents
that I represent in my district when I
talk to people in my district about
electricity they sometimes complain
about the cost but the single biggest
thing they complain about is their
electricity being
interrupted they complain about the fact
that it gets interrupted and they
complain about the fact that when it is
interrupted sometimes those disruptions
last for hours and in some rare cases
days and people get extremely upset when
they have no
power reliability is a huge
concern and as reports from nerk have
reported out extensively over the last
two
years as we
increase the number of renewable
generation sources on the
grid we also increase the
instability and the unreliability of the
grid compounding that problem is the
premature retirement of existing power
power generation
sources it affects coal more than
anything else but it can affect nuclear
it can affect even natural
gas so Rel reliability is an extremely
important issue that we need to
confront as legislators and as
Regulators across the United
States the Genesis for this bill House
Bill
FN was an attempt by myself to modify
the renewable portfolio standard to
support nuclear
energy OS actually created for me a bill
that changed our renewable portfolio
standard into a clean energy standard or
a zero emissions energy
standard and
it was actually a fairly clean
bill and it added nuclear energy to that
to
the sources of electricity generation
that could be compensated via the
RPS and I added nuclear in a tiny tiny
amount
0.1% of the megawatt hours of a Nuclear
Generating
plant could be
compensated as a class one RPS uh and
cell class one RPS zero emission Rex
Zex as they were
called and so I comp computed the did
the math to compute how much this would
cost for cab Brook alone it would cost
about $3 million a
year and the amount of money that se
Brook would get out of that roughly $3
million a year wouldn't make much
difference to their bottom
line but the worst part about that
situation was that the RPS is not a
state-only
program it's a regional program and in
fact it's a national
program so if you let
sebr
collect monies by selling Zex you also
have to let Millstone down in
Connecticut sell those Zs you also have
to let nuclear power plants from any RPS
state in the country sell those rcks so
the cost of this program could Skyrocket
quickly from the $3 million that I
originally calculated to tens maybe even
hundreds of millions of dollars well
there's no way I could ask New Hampshire
rate payers to pay hundreds of millions
of dollars to uh support nuclear
energy even though it would benefit us
all so I had to abandon that idea and as
all of you have submitted bills this
year knows OS was backed up badly this
fall so I didn't get my zeec bill my
zero
emissions
uh standard Bill until like two days
before the OS deadline which was
November
17th as I recall somewhere in
there so once I realized that I had to
abandon that approach I had two days to
come up with an alternative
approach and House Bill 1644 FN is the
alternative approach that I came up
with what I turned the bill into was a
department of energy
investigation on how
to
support nuclear energy and other
noncarbon emitting energy
sources and I used as a template for
that bill a bill that we had had earlier
in committee last year to study micro
grids and so much of the structure of
this bill and uh some of
the
individual recommendations and
examination areas are variations on what
was in that micr Grid
bill and it has become apparent since I
filed that bill
originally that some of these probably
are too broad for the study that I want
this the invest the department to do for
this
investigation so I probably would like
to work with the committee to
make some changes to
this language to come up with a narrower
Focus for the Department's
investigation now you may have seen in
your email that the the department is
going to oppose this
bill uh later this afternoon and they're
going to oppose it because it is too
broad and they don't think that they can
do justice to an investigation that is
this Broad
so I think that there is still a way
forward if we can narrow the focus of
this investigation to something that the
dep Department would become feel
comfortable
doing and we can still make an attempt
to find
out for example what other states are
doing to
support nuclear energy I know there is a
proposal before the Connecticut
legislature to add nuclear to their
RPS it hasn't been passed it's
controversial but there is an attempt to
do that down
there and other states are likely to be
doing something similar and the
Department's investigation can find out
what other states are doing and make
recommendations about what we might be
able to do here in New Hampshire to
support nuclear energy we sort of had
this discussion earlier today on how
House
Bill well I forgotten the number now but
the house bill that Keith anman
introduced that was recommended by his
uh commission that studied nuclear
energy for the better part of a year
which was the result of a bill we passed
out of this committee last year or the
year before so I think there is an
appetite I think there is a
recognition that we need to figure out a
way to raised the Public's awareness
that if we're looking for non-carbon
emitting
energy nucle nuclear energy
is probably the best source that we can
find and if we can find ways to support
it support its
development then we need to do that we
need to save the nuclear plants that are
in existence today for example Seabrook
is licensed through 2050
and it would be pretty detrimental I
think to ISO New England and to New
Hampshire specifically
if seab Brook was to be decommissioned
before
2050 2050 is not that far away it might
seem like it
but uh as someone of a certain age I can
tell you the 25 years between now and
then is not that long
so that's the essence of what this bill
is you can read the specifics here and
we can discuss them we can either do it
at this public hearing this afternoon
I'll take notes or we can wait uh for a
work session and maybe discuss some of
the language at that time so I'm not
going to say anything more about it for
now I'll uh entertain your questions if
you want to want to ask them and uh then
I guess there'll be other people behind
me who will chime in on this uh
particular issue so thank you well I
have a question um I'll do the prog
first is uh number one I assume when
you're talking about the uh the um uh
nuclear energy you're talking about a
dispatchable form of of U of energy in
terms of what we really need to
concentrate on if if we lose that we
lose a a a large portion of dispatchable
type energy as opposed to the um
renewable which is uh you know not
always
reliable exactly that's why nuclear is
so key because it's dispatchable right
and uh that's why we need to preserve
what we have and develop new sources of
nuclear energy in the future yeah and my
follow-up comment would be the um if I
remember correctly this would be kind of
in line with a notice that ISO New
England put out a couple of years ago in
terms of a um feeling that we are at
risk for brownouts due to um lack of
generators that may be falling offline
or the amount of years it may take to
bring new generators online and so they
issued a a warning for the utilities to
develop a plan of attack should a brown
out happen so this would fall in line
with us us to prepare for and look at
future uh Electrical uh uh generation
opportunities absolutely not just ISO
New England but nerk the North
American uh energy reliability Council
which is under the as opes of
FK U their primary responsibility is
reliability and they're warning us they
have wond us repeatedly in the last year
and a half that our grid is becoming
less and less Rel iable due to premature
generation plant closings and to the uh
development of more uh renewable energy
resources which are not spinning
resources and can destabilize the grid
without a lot of el additional
electrical equipment to maintain the uh
electrical stability of the grid
so there's a lot here that has to be
done and um as asking the doe to look
into this question I think is a good
place to
start okay question that representative
Ms has a question thank you and thank
you Mr chair for taking my question um
and I'm sorry if I missed this but it
sounded like um your your real original
intent of this bill and what you'd like
to get back to is to focus specifically
on nuclear is that
correct yes I think nuclear is the our
best chance going forward to find a
non-carbon emitting resource that can
provide the amount of electricity that
we're going to need in the future
followup followup you you started your
um your testimony by talking about
reliability and how important that was
and I don't think anybody disagrees with
you if that is the concern wouldn't it
be worthwhile if we're going to ask the
department of energy to do a study to
look at the reliability of all different
all energy sources so that we get a true
picture of where things
stand I don't think the department of
energy is the right organization to do
that
examination reliability in New Hampshire
and in ISO New England states is the
responsibility of iso New England and
they do do reliability studies they
spend a lot of time analyzing
reliability there are reliability
studies out there available for oo
England in addition to that there's lots
of reliability studies from nerk and
other organizations so there's
not an absence of reliability studies
out there there's plenty of them and I
don't think the asking the doe to do
undertake such a reliability study would
augment
the information that's already extent on
the
subject
representative Corman thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question uh so as as you often ask we
should look at the text of the bill so
I'm looking at the text of the bill and
uh when I look at um me here
line oh lines 10 and 11 um so uh lines
10 11 in particular talks about nuclear
Advanced geothermal and storage
Technologies um so in in your view as
this Bill gets amended would the
geothermal and storage technology still
be considered part of the bill or are
you thinking of dropping those out and
just focusing on nuclear I'd be willing
to discuss leaving those in with regard
to those two particular lines I think we
should probably
delete a definition of clean energy
there is no current definition of clean
energy and Statute in New Hampshire and
it's a pretty
broad
open-ended uh term that's used to mean a
lot of different things these days so I
think we should probably get rid of that
term Al together and focus on non-carbon
emitting
Technologies and I included Advanced
geothermal and storage
Technologies for a reason and that is to
indicate that while I think nuclear is
is key it's not the only non-carbon
emitting technology that out there that
might be worthy of some
support now if we're going to try to
narrow the focus of this investigation
we might have to drop those because
um it might it might be involve too much
work on the part of the department to be
able to handle that too but I thought it
was at least worth exploring exploring
whether those two things should be part
of the equation or
not representative partial has a
question thank you chair and thank you
for your testimony
um I've heard reliability is something
to look at and I've heard about
dispatchability and I guess one of my
questions is um well there's two I'll
that's them all together one is my
understanding is while nuclear is a good
base load supplier of energy it lacks
somewhat in its dispatchability
um that's one concern I would have the
other which I'm
really thinking is that if we are
looking at nuclear as as part of this
bill but not investigating other um
alternatives are we getting a clear
picture of what our best path forward is
I've heard a lot of talk about being
energy agnostic in this committee and
I'm wondering if something like this is
actually putting our thumb on a
particular uh
technology and and and I'm I'm I'm
asking this because I really don't
know it may sound like I okay thank you
I'll answer your first question or your
second question first about energy
agnosticism the reason I
added Advanced geothermal and storage te
Technologies was to make it a little
more energy
agnostic but as I said just a moment ago
it may broaden the investigation to the
point where it becomes too much for the
Department to handle so we might have to
think about removing that would it be
nice to leave it in yes and maybe the
department can tell us later whether
they could handle something like that or
not you other question about the
dispatchability of nuclear I think once
you have a chance to read and I think
every Committee Member has now a copy of
the report done by the nuclear study
commission that we set up with House
Bill
543 I think when you have a chance to
read that report you'll see that small
nuclear reactors are more will be more
able to deal with questions of
dispatchability than the large um
lightwater reactors that we have today
so while it's probably true that nuclear
is
not quickly dispatchable
today that may not be the case in the
future repr
Thomas thank you Mr chair or Mr Vice
chair um on line uh
22 um you talk about cyber security and
and physical security standards for
clean energy am I understanding now that
that it's the cyber security and
physical security standards for
Nuclear So This is a artifact of the
fact that I stole this oh language from
the micro Grid bill and I think the
department of Energy's concern about the
broad nature of this
bill is at least in part the result of
their concern about the line you just
cited cyber security and physical
security may be outside the scope of
something that they have the ability to
do so I would argue that when we discuss
whether or not we want to try to amend
this bill that might be something that
have would have to come out thank
you represent keny did you have your can
up yeah it's a it's a a question and
sort of a comment too um yeah although
nuclear is mainly designed to provide
base load power to you know to have
nuclear reactors that can load follow
has been something that's of interest
for you know 10 or 20 years I mean G
Itachi has an ATM reactor they haven't
built one but that's one that's been
designed I I can't remember the exact
rate of you know load following that
it's capable of but I mean if there is a
concern there I mean that is something
that you know designers of new nuclear
re actors are thinking
about not a question I guess no not a
question but uh thank you for pointing
that out uh I stated
that in more broad terms just a moment
ago but your specifics are are
welcome representative
rolds thank you Mr Vice chairman um yeah
my question is just in my comment is
kind of a follow on to the last couple
of questions I was I was gratified to
see that you um in fact had
included uh the
term storage
Technologies because going to the
comments earlier and the concern about
energy sources being
dispatchable
storage makes renewable Technologies
so I certainly would like to see the
inclusion of wind and solar energy in
any kind of study of energy resources
that are being were being undertaken
along with storage capacity because I
won't I won't repeat myself uh that
makes that makes sense
um yeah I'll just leave it
there well I didn't exactly hear a
question there but I will say based on
what you what you what your statement
was that that would broaden the scope of
this investigation to the point where
I'm sure the doe couldn't handle it so
the whole purpose of trying to focus
this investigation is to produce
something that would be useful but still
within the scope of what the department
can
handle and I think we know aot
about
uh wind energy we have within state
government right now the office of
offshore wind development so I don't
think we need to
uh lump
wind into this study storage
maybe because storage while you're right
it can deal to some degree with the
dispatchability of renewable
energy right now storage is incredibly
expensive and pretty Limited in its
capability so um I don't know to what
degree storage could will be useful
going forward unless somebody comes up
with
a a new way to do it but certainly if
somebody does come up with a new way of
doing it it it'll be extremely
invaluable and
important okay I think we're starting to
cover the same territory so I'd like to
give
uh well I'll give the last two questions
I'll go with uh representative uh McGee
first and then we'll finish with the
representative JD Bernardi
representative McGee thank you Mr chair
Mr current chair um okay
um I'm looking at the letter from the
Department of energy and their
discussion of sort of the regional
reporting that's available in terms of
the grid G stability and you started out
saying that your concern for grid
stability was where this began and then
some of the language came from a micro
you know other bills so so it's I can
understand the department of energy
saying hey if you're going to give us
something tell us how to get there so my
question is should we maybe Focus um
thinking now and even in our work
session on the outcomes that we're
trying to achieve because we all have
our opinions
about uh reliability and dispatchability
and
preferences but it looks like um since
we don't have a plan that we're
following in terms of uh what we're
trying to transition in our Energy
System right we're not following a
blueprint right now of where we need to
get to so we're kind of throwing stuff
out there I'm wondering if we could talk
about what the outcomes we would like
them to present us with when we get that
report back
are um because I'm I think they would be
informed by all of the um planning
reports that are available through ISO
on what's being looked at in terms of
grid
reliability and I I I don't want us to
go into it asking them to come out with
the solution that we're prescribing
right I want to see them give us
information uh of what's going to create
a stable grid the
future um or you know what are we trying
to get to in 5 or 10 years
so um I guess my question would be are
you open to make if this bill is going
to be a study uh from the Department of
energy then are you open to the idea of
us figuring out what questions they need
to answer just give them a list of what
they need to come back to us with so
that we can do something with
that well the language of the bill does
State what we want the outome to be in
lines 26 and 27 it says
provide that the investigation will
produce a report that provides financial
and
Regulatory support for non-carbon
emitting energy electricity generation
that balances Economic Development grid
stability security costs and potential
impacts that kind of thing
so we do know what we would like to see
for an a result uh so to your
question Are there specific questions
that we can ask to get that result and I
would argue
that potentially yes we can we can
rework the language of a through H
eliminating G to make sure we ask the
right questions to get the output that
we want
uh as listed in lines 25 through 27 yes
and and in followup followup yeah so I
uh had un underlined those as well I had
underlined those lines because they do
give specificity but they are still
quite Broad and I think the issue that
comes out here is that these Concepts
while good uh can be balanced very
different ways so if you're looking at
Economic Development versus Grid
stability versus security versus costs
right you can can come at that a million
different ways and come out with a lot
of different answers so I would think
that they would need more from us in
order to figure out which way to weigh
those things in terms of what we're
trying to uh achieve so I think it's a
great one for for a work
session you could be right uh about um
offering them more as a matter of fact I
think you are right and I was H that the
committee would agree to do a work
session to see if we can come up with
some of those specific
questions okay representative Bary you
have the last
word thank you Mr Vice chair uh so is it
within the scope of your concept of a of
of a
u a bill here to have the doe
potentially contract with the Department
of energy in Washington with and through
un to uh get get some um funds to really
understand what it would take to uh
Advance nuclear engineering Solutions in
New
Hampshire well I'm not going to speak
for the Department of energy when they
testify you can ask them um how they
Envision this happening hiring a
consultant I think might be something
that they would lean toward or consider
and there is no funding for that in this
legislation so that would be an issue
that we'd have to consider if we were
going to try to carry this
forward okay thank you uh I think we'll
move on thank you representative o for
your testimony and explanations and I
will invite our last speaker Mr Griffin
Rao from the Department of energy who re
excuse me re I'm getting confused with v
and RAR but uh I'm sure they will tell
us everything we need to know about how
doe is going to uh work on this bill for
us thank you Mr chairman uh for the
record Griffin Roberge State energy
program manager at the New Hampshire
Department of energy um as was
previously mentioned and in a letter of
testimony going around the room and in
an email last night um the department is
opposed to the bill as introduced uh for
many of the reasons that uh
representative V had indicated um going
through the bill and I'll just keep it
at a fairly high level because I think
most people might be familiar with the
letter um the investigation topics are
quite broad as they are currently
written um some of them are more focused
uh or looked at at Regional or national
levels um as has been mentioned uh ISO
New England does a number of um
reliability studies um at the regional
level um there's also been a couple of
other uh related uh reports from enr um
nerk uh other organizations such as that
um given the broadness of the um
investigation we did as noted in the
fiscal note anticipate that the
consultant costs uh to undertake this
investigation could be north of
$250,000 um we do not have the current
Staffing Resources to man out a very
broad investigation as is currently
written um given that some of the tasks
would likely Fall outside of the
Department's regulation of electric
distribution utilities um we could not
assess the costs for that consultant to
them so it would raise the question of
whether or not it would be appro
for uh a state appropriation be made to
retain a consultant to do the study and
then finally as has been mentioned um
cyber security we would suggest removing
that um section entirely in the bill as
it's currently written um while the
department does review some cyber
security plans for our electric
distribution utilities um doing it doing
so for a variety of clean energy
resources is could be highly sensitive
very complex because is traditionally
overseen by FK and nerk um I'm done with
acronyms that concludes my testimony
thank you very much Happy take any
questions representative
Berardi Mr robar you heard my uh
question to uh representative B earlier
I hear that Contracting with the
doe uh in Washington for some funds
focused on getting Consultants as well
as Maybe engag ing the University of New
Hampshire they engineering folks in uh
doing a comprehensive look at this issue
sure and thank you for the question
so in terms of Contracting I guess with
the US Department of energy wouldn't
just be something we contact them and we
just do it usually they yeah I know uh
usually they offer um competitive
opportunities for um research grants and
that type of thing and UNH certainly
does have a history of applying to to
some of them to uh procure funding to do
studies but at times USD will offer that
funding specifically for a certain area
of study such as say solar or Hydro
demonstrations or that type of thing um
it's something we could certainly look
into I'm not going to sit here today and
pledge that there certainly is something
that we could do in that vein so thank
you for the
question representative
Mill thank you and thank you Mr Rob
taking my question it just struck me as
as we were talking about uh us doe and
what's going on New Hampshire is
currently putting together a climate
action plan that they're going to be
submitting for review to the feds in
terms of funding of that plan and it's
designed to look at a transition to more
non-emitting
um forms of energy so I'm wondering
whether the bill could be converted into
a bill to have doe work along with Dees
to make sure that nuclear is incl
included in the plan that maybe you know
because that's a plan that's actually
forward- facing that's looking at how
are we meeting our emissions lowering
goals M and so that's a place where you
maybe could get some traction and some
money and some funding and some looks uh
at a level where they actually have the
expertise and the information about what
the latest and greatest Technologies are
so I'm just wondering if if we could
Define what we were trying to achieve
M uh in terms of bringing greater
reliability to the regional grid as a
state if we could be telling that to the
doe as part of our plan then maybe that
would be a way for us to get somewhere
rather than just having another study
yeah sure and uh thank you for the for
the question so I I guess I could say it
there's a potential maybe for that I'm
not going to sit here and pledge that
that is I would just know that you know
I know Dees is the lead agency in
crafting the state's climate action plan
and I know that there are federal
deadlines to get that plan in place I
just wouldn't want to be putting Dees in
a position to slow down the development
of the plan waiting for this legislation
to be sorted out so just something to
consider but I understand the point
thank
you I have one last question just out of
C uh curiosity do you see
um considering this bill and the one we
heard earlier
1465 do you see where the two of them
could be done like if if they were both
passed would would they be combined in
in in Doe's efforts sure I I I think I
understand what you're saying so um yes
thank you for the question is that I I
think that is something for this
committee to consider is that those
bills could potentially overlap one
another so for example in the bill we
heard earlier today House Bill 1465 that
bill could potentially be creating a
coordinat position at the department um
depending on what the final bill
language looks like if signed in the law
you know it could be pre creating a
coordinator position while also you know
I'm sorry I should back up a coordinator
position that's responsible
for uh compiling reports and continuing
studies from State agencies on nuclear
matters while also the department is
doing a similar investigation in another
vein so I I guess my they could
complement each other but I would say
that they could also overlap one another
and be a little bit duplicative thank
you seeing no other questions thank you
very much for your testimony thank you
seeing no other pink cards or testifiers
I will declare this uh public hearing
closed Mr
chair representative Ms has a question
um I just wanted to let uh my colleagues
know that um representative Williams and
I are uh working on an amendment to HB
1472 which is the EV incentive pilot
program I had hop to have a draft of the
amendment available before we left today
but what I'd like to do is just
circulate kind of an outline for
everyone that kind of gives them a sense
of what will be in that that outline
that Amendment and I will have that
tomorrow
okay all right so we completed our work
for
today at least our public hearing work
all of us have homework however because
during the course of the day we have
circulated a number of
amendments that we will be considering
during exec session
tomorrow and um so I hope that each of
you will go home tonight with these
amendments and study them and come
tomorrow prepared to discuss them and U
pass judgment on
them
now I didn't realize at the time that we
wouldn't that we would need more time on
uh House
Bill 1465 so I scheduled that for exec
session tomorrow but representative
Harrington and representative
muns would like to work together on an
amendment that uh creates a single
position within the department of
energy
to accumulate and report on all the
information that all these other
departments that are listed in statute
are currently charged with trying to uh
capture so we're going to need more time
obviously to work on that so tomorrow
I'm going to open the exec session on
hb1
1465 and then immediately recess it so
that representative Harrington and muns
can work together on an amendment to
that
bill
and since we're also considering that
maybe the bill that we just heard hb1
1644 might dovetail somehow with
1465 maybe we'll try to Acom um
accomplish some kind of an amalgamation
of those two bills um at the same time
I'll let representative muns and
representative Harrington look at that
question to see if there's an
opportunity
for
uh for us to make put those two bills
together somehow if
possible but other than that we will go
through the other bills
um that are listed in the calendar for
tomorrow and we'll pass judgment on all
of those and we've got amendments I
think for just about every single one of
them so it'll be a busy time and um I'll
look forward to seeing everybody here
tomorrow now I know that representative
liwicki
has an appointment at 2:15 off site but
he expects to be here by 3:00
so hopefully uh everybody will be able
to be here tomorrow we haven't heard
recently from Representatives Summers
rney uh MC
Williams I think we've heard
representative cren I haven't heard from
her but hopefully we'll have a full
house tomorrow for executive session so
we'll see everybody then and I hope
everybody has a safe ride home it looks
like it's snowing again
Mr chair
yes representative PL uh thank you uh I
believe there's going to be an amendment
for House Bill 1700 have you an update
on that thank I have not uh
representative Potenza said that she
would be creating an amendment but I
have not seen it representative Thomas
has created an amendment for that bill
so if representative
Penza fails to create said Amendment we
have one or if the amendment she creates
is not acceptable we have one so we'll
see you tomorrow thank you you have it
representative
penzes if you
could we'll delay a few minutes until we
can get a copy of that uh that bill so
that we'll at least have a chance to
look at that
one now I believe I passed out
okay so the amendment to House Bill
1700 that representative Vice chair
Thomas has created is
a uh strictly just a repeal of RSA 12-
F unless it's what person that wrote it
that wrot
un it's in our committee no it's it's in
our committee it's our bill anybody can
write an amendment but the only person
who can introduce amendment is a member
of this committee so you can hand out
the amendment to us because our B we're
going to be responsible for introducing
the
amend yeah we
won't so there is
a hang on hang on there is some
speculation that representative penza's
Amendment repeals RSA
12f but also has some language about and
representative PL can you Enlighten us
what her additional language might
be to be honest no I have not seen a
draft it is in the works okay I saw some
email that indicated she was going to do
something with the Air National Guard
but um I until we see it we can't
imagine what that would be but just in
case we have our own Amendment which
just strictly repeals 12f RSA 12f which
is the weather modification statute and
uh so if re representative penza's
Amendment isn't suitable we'll have a
suitable replacement for
it uh representative partiall yes while
we're waiting I have a question of the
chair if I may um earlier today I found
myself in an uncomfortable position of
asking one of our testifiers about
something that was really not part of
their preview um I know we have you have
the pink cards in front of you is I
can't think of any way to do this but
maybe you can is there anybody to share
who is going to be testifying in the
course of a a presentation of a bill so
we can gear our questions to be most
appropriate to um that to the people
testifying well that's a good question
and a a good thought I'd entertain
responses from the rest of the committee
off the top of my head I would say that
once I get a stack of pink cards I could
read them to you to let you know who's
planning to
testify most of the names would probably
be meaningless to you unless it was Mr
robarge or um some someone from Dees I
could do that but the problem is during
the course of a hearing the pink card
list the pink card stack
grows so I would be hesitant to read the
whole stack multiple times throughout
the the course of the hearing but um I'm
open to other suggestions representative
Vice chair Thomas I'm sorry did you uh
is a question of of uh not knowing who's
coming on deck or just not understanding
understanding the name of the person
talking at the time well it's it's
knowing who's coming on deck and if your
question might be better if my question
might be better held to address to that
person rather than or or if it's a
question of uh you know I should have
asked to the last person that testified
but I thought oh for an example I
thought we'd have somebody uh here to
testify about phyto blooms in our Lakes
today and on one particular Bill and
that did not happen and I wanted to get
that as part of our
um inquiry here today so I end up asking
Mr roar's a question that was totally
out of his belly Wick and I and I hate
doing that I don't know of a good
solution though I mean I suppose he
could prob me lay him up on the table
but then we have to get up and look at
them I don't think that work I I I think
if if the list is not too long if
there's anybody that's here from a
department or something um perhaps a
mention could be made who's turned in a
a pink card but as far as anybody else
speaking you could have like like the
chair said they they come and they go
they have a long list be names would be
forgotten by then so so I don't I don't
know a real answer to that what if we
the SCH we let know who was scheduled to
speak before any cards are passed up
would that be a that that could be very
you know if you get 30 people that could
be a long list too I guess well I could
announce uh right at the very beginning
of the hearing who I have pink cards
from at at that moment as long as you
understand that that list could change
as the as the hearing weighs on
frequently I have people handing in pink
cards um when I announce the last pink
card then I get a new one you know like
today I I said we're going to give the
last word to and I forgot who it was
soand so and then I get a pink card as
soon as that person sits down so they
weren't the last one so that can happen
but but but I would be willing to
attempt to announce who's in the in the
initial list of pink cards and if that
would be helpful we can try it we can
experiment with it ju just think of it
as the starting
lineup just think of it as the starting
lineup the starting lineup that's a
that's a good analogy I I I do think
though that it's perfectly fine to put
Mr Roberge on the spot at any point well
that is true that is
true that's why he makes the big bucks
after all
right good thank
you
all right I don't want to hold anybody
if you need to leave um feel free we're
waiting for another amendment
um but if you if you feel you need to
lead just go right
ahead that's not an amendment it's an
outline for proposed
amendment this outline was given to OS
and they're working on it but the exact
language we won't have till tomorrow
apparently all right so I'm going to
officially adjourn this meeting and
those of you who want to wait around for
the additional amendment can do so
otherwise you're free to leave safe ride
home and we'll see you right and early
tomorrow morning thank you
so